electronically
this is a pretty orientation followed by
members of
[Music]
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order and confirming that one
all members of the Canadian select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously tremendous
meaning through Zoom electronic meeting
platform again the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information have
been made available from the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on general core website
two the notice that this meeting
uh
notice what this notice complies with
house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
in the event that the public isn't able
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
I want to introduce the staff at ironde
Manning helping us today our committee
of researcher Brad gramlin thank you
much
and please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by a roll call only I don't foresee that
happening today but nonetheless let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which was required another
hello
Madam clerk we can't hear you at all I
can hear you're mumbling something but
there's no microphone near you
uh this is Mike can you hear me now
without my mask yes
thank you
representative Hill
here and there is no one with me
thank you representative Aaron
I'm here in the committee room
you know representative I hope I say
representative
representative borski
I am here and there's nobody in the room
representative Sykes
representative Sykes is present and
there's in his home and no one is here
representative Cleaver is going to be
arriving a little late this morning
thank you
representative Pickering
I'm here and I'm in the room alone
representative rich
representative Fenton is here can you
hear me now no I can thank you
good
representative Pulaski
representative is here and alone in my
home and I believe representative rich
just was able to unmute I just unmuted
I'm here and my husband is nearby thank
you
uh
representative Fox is here I am viewing
the meeting alone however my husband is
in and out of the house
representative Stevens
ah excuse me good morning here alone in
my home
thank you and representative Dalo
representative value is here and I am
alone
all right thank you
um let's get started I'm going to put a
few things to go over in terms of our
orientation I did also call in three
department heads and uh and another
normal regular face and transportation
and get started with that probably about
9 30.
um uh actually I know we just did a roll
call and it might seem kind of redundant
but uh could it helped for I think
everybody's benefit so let's do an
introduction
um just to you know not just your name
but where you're from
what you represent what town you
represent
so if we want to get started with that
um I'll start with myself my name is
Thomas Walsh
um I've been born in Manchester
rich in the late 1966. in books since
chair
man my name is Larry gagne I'm from
Manchester's Awards
City
moved here from Canada in 1950 when I
was six years old I've been in
Manchester all my life
and this is my seventh term
it's a problem
good morning
um I'm representative Carol Crawford I
represent Carroll District Four which is
moultonborough Tuftonboro and sandwich
this is my fifth term and I've always
been in transportation
I've lived most of my life up in
Willingboro
representative Aaron
good morning everyone I'm Judy Aaron and
I am representing Sullivan County
district 7 which is comprised of the
towns of Acworth Goshen Langdon
Leominster and Washington
and this is my second term I'm also a
member of the environment agriculture
committee I'm a vice chair and I am
happy to be on this new committee and
look forward to working with all of you
attack
ing here
um again we'll particular order just on
Mr chairman we couldn't hear who you
announced or asked for
say again too much yeah uh Mr chairman I
don't know who you wanted to go first on
screen but I couldn't hear the name that
you mentioned
representative worsky
thank you thank you good morning
everyone my name is Ted Gorski
originally from Cambridge Massachusetts
uh moved up to New Hampshire back in the
mid 80s
I Live Now in Bedford for the last 18
years I represent uh Bedford Hillsboro
seven and this is my uh my first term
morning everybody my name is George
Sykes I'm represented from Grafton 13
which is the city of Lebanon
um
I've lived in Lebanon for over 30 years
and this is my fifth term on the
transportation committee and I've that's
been the only committee that I've served
on in those five terms
good morning I'm rep I'm Drew Fox and I
represent Cheshire six
I'm from Keen Ward 3. this is my first
term and my first choice for uh
good morning my name is Laura tularski I
represent Nashua Ward 8 which is
Hillsboro 35.
um I grew up in Nashua and I am now
representing the city in my second term
and I was in transportation last term
and I just want to congratulate the new
clerk I'm thrilled to see representative
Crawford working as clerk this term
foreign
Stratford 18 which is Somersworth and
representative Stevens
good morning uh Deb Stevens here and I
represent Nashua Ward 7 which is also
where I grew up
yeah did I say second term yes
second term
hi everybody I'm Donovan Fenton
um I represent Keen Ward five uh this is
my third term uh second term on
Transportation my first term was on
environment and agriculture but uh I'm
glad to be back we got a great uh
committee here and I'm very excited so
it's good to see you all again
thank you
to representative
hi there uh my name is Dan vayu I'm a
first term representative from Amherst
Hillsboro 22. I'm originally originally
from Maine and spent a little time in
Exile down in DC and Baltimore
um looking forward to uh work we do this
year
public representative Hill
good morning Mr chairman
um my name is Greg Hill I live in
Northfield New Hampshire uh have lived
here for 35 or so years this is my fifth
or sixth term I haven't really done the
math I've served on a number of
different committees election law uh
education labor
um
now I am the chair of legislative
Administration I'm also the chair of
school building authority
um that's about it
um I look forward to my first term on
Transportation
good morning I'm representative Dan
Pickering I'm from Hancock that's
Hillsboro District 3. it includes
Bennington and Greenfield
and this is my second term and it's also
my second turn on Transportation
thank you
representative
good morning Mr chairman my name is
Aidan Ankerberg I represent Stratford
district 10 which is Ward 3 in the Lilac
City of Rochester New Hampshire
and we just had another member join us
representative from Allenstown Merrimack
District 22.
um I'm a freshman representative and I'm
looking forward to uh working and
learning with all of you
shut that window I can't see my screen
did I miss anybody
well anyway uh first of all
I guess I failed to mention this is a
fair modification as well
in my opinion we've all volunteered to
get on the best Committee in the house
on any given day when we're in a normal
circumstance
used to be
even the lobbyists that didn't have any
bills
but always had the transportation
because it's
like I said the best committee
I've just got a few things to go over
quick because like I said we've done
some guests
including
um just some recommended
that you all know to get started
I just recommended that you use a single
email legislative business
I know people have gotten a state one
but
need one
excuse me
um dressing decorum
although there isn't actually a
dictates anything up in the Forum
we uh we did address professionally we
are representing our
towns
uh food coffee lunch breaks it's going
to be a little different obviously
because we are
in this situation but as a rule there's
no food during public hearings for sure
or exec sessions coffee Etc if you need
any drinks or want anything I usually
hide mine right underneath the uh the
table it just makes for much more
professional appearance
uh again the exception for that will be
obviously for the members that are here
in person for our lunch break will be
probably eating right here
uh use some electronic devices that's uh
this one's gone back and forth and I one
time we were asked as committee members
just out of respect for the people that
are here testifying do not use them
during our hearings
um that's changed obviously in the world
of coven as you can see everybody I
think's got one uh what I ask is that
you're respectful of them
when the public is speaking uh please
don't bury your head behind the screen
you know
be aware that they're here uh and um
we're here to listen that's their
opportunity
uh please if you're going to use it in
in our hearings uh I hope it's for
legislative
reasons only that Candy Crush who are
three Excel or whatever the union
leaders got to say
again most of this is common sense but
um if and when we do get back to our
room which is officially room 203
um hopefully sooner than later but we'll
see how that goes uh all committee
members do have a draw
in in our particular room again mention
it hopefully when that day comes I'll
um
for those members that are here
obviously there are placards around the
building in case of an emergency
and for security we'll deal with that
[Music]
no
um
just for some of our general rules of
the balance between the priorities right
now we've committed we have 19 members
and 10 Republicans nine Democrats
uh committee saving obviously I haven't
done it at this point yet
um I didn't know who was going to be
here in person right now it's uh
first come first serve I'll see how that
pans out again if we do ever get back in
our room then we'll make sure we have an
official seating assignment
um our typical build topics
I won't go through that I think you're
going to find out in a few minutes from
our department heads that are going to
be here introducing themselves and make
a better idea
and
researcher in our system well obviously
if you're sending out notices but always
uh if there's any doubt check the
calendar that comes out every Thursday
public hearings I guess that's the most
important thing we can talk about for
those that are new to our committee or
um the public hearing is just what it
says it's a public hearing it's their
opportunity the citizens of the state to
come here and let them let us know how
they feel on us on a certain build
again it's our job at that time to to
listen
um I've seen members in the past have
launched way too much C-SPAN they showed
up in our committee rooms of the hearing
thinking they were on
Senate investigation committee that's
not what we do with the public
we don't want to get into debates with
them
what we can do though is ask questions
and we certainly
um
should be doing that
um all questions will go through the
chair and if you haven't been in one of
these formats you'll see soon how it
works uh just about any communication
that happens in a committee does go
through the chair
um if you were a sponsor of a committee
uh if you're a sponsor of a building
committee uh what happens in this
situation if you're gonna if the bill is
in this committee and you are a sponsor
you can introduce the bill once you do
introduce it
um if you're here you can remain return
to your seat but you're not going to be
allowed to participate in any more
questioning of anybody's had to buy or
it's only clear if you get one bite at
the Apple and that's when you're
introducing it keep in mind once we have
the executive session on that then
obviously you can participate with
um
which is an old book it says no action
on Bill same day as hearing that's
traditionally how it's been in the house
generally we have our public hearings on
one day for a bill and then we'll do our
exact session on a different day the
rule did change we are allowed to exec
on same day
we'll see how that goes
take it day by day I have had a
discussion with the ranking member on if
we do that
the opportunities for uh caucuses are
going to be there
I'm not planning on that today that some
will still work out
next week I did post
well when I sent my post in for an
executive session they actually didn't
put in the calendar uh still giving us
the levity to do what you need just to
here's my voice too by the way I think
it's my first day as chair I'm starting
to lose it
might have something to do with first
winning all night last night
um
the public has their opportunity to
speak at the public hearing nobody from
the public will be inputting the
executive session without my consent uh
occasionally we do look at our
department heads of people that may have
an answer to a question that's important
and allow it but for the most part the
executive section is our time to debate
um amendments prepared by OLS is that
I'm not going to get into that right now
if you've got any particular questions
on that approach me later I know how it
used to be but again with Colvin uh
things are a little different on the
amendment process if you've got any
questions on that we'll let me know
individually
uh emotions again for most of us that
are returning you get it you know what's
going on as far as the Motions that are
typical whether it's an expedient to
legislate
to pass
Etc there are others uh for the freshmen
I guess the easiest thing to do is just
to watch and see how this all pans out
it won't take long and it's actually an
interesting process what we do
um
any questions again don't hesitate to
ask anybody if it's been around
but lastly on our executive sessions
um again this goes to our freshman more
than anybody with every bill that we
vote on in our executive session that
vote is actually just a recommendation
to go to the Full House
every bill that's introduced in the
house has to be voted on by the Full
House what we do in committee is just
vote on our recommendation
and
if at the end of the vote we have to
report for the calendar for the benefit
of everybody else in the house
we not supposed to call them gloves
anymore that's what they are
but they're actually officially a
committee report
by majority report and sometimes you'll
see a Minority Report as well
and that's just stating the positions of
the members of the committee that voted
each week or each in a certain way
we get to votes that are unanimous say
we had a 19-0 to recommend ought to pass
there is a thing called the consent
calendar promotion can be made to move
it to consent and that's a group of
bills that when we get to host session
we'll be voted on by the house with one
vote instead of going line by line bill
by Bill you'll see that for unanimous
maybe one or two dissenters if there's
no objection
and I know that's how they're all going
to pass out and committee this year so
because I'm looking at the clock I want
to put out a big thanks for our staff Mr
Brad Greenland he's our committee
researcher and Rebecca Stewart is our
committee assistant these people who've
helped me out tremendously to get going
I asked you have some patience with me I
am certainly not the most technological
Advanced person you I could build you
around staircase with my eyes closed but
this is a learning curve for me so
I hope you can tolerate me answering
um what I'll do I've got a few minutes
so I've got to run over quickly are
there any questions from anybody right
now before we get into
around
hi this is representative Sykes oh I'm
sorry representative but anyways um
I just wanted to say I admire your uh
optimism and I hope that it all proves
to be true that's one thing about this
committee that we we generally can find
our way to be
um cordial and
really do a good job of examining issues
and thank you for that moment
thank you Mr chairman I know the
scheduling is been a big challenge for
the staff but acknowledging that we're
meeting this week on a Friday and next
week on a Friday do you have any idea
for our own scheduling purposes what we
might be doing moving forward
yeah thank you for that well as you know
usually it's us as a committee to get to
decide what day
um right now that's the it's the
speaker's office because it's all double
rooms that's actually picking the day
that we're allowed to use a room and
we've got Friday and next week as well
as this week obviously it's not my
favorite day either
I will reach out to the uh speaker's
office to get an indication that whether
we're going to be on Fridays or if it's
going to be changing there is a chance
it could change in the future because as
other other committees finish up their
bills
there are some that only have a handful
for example
there might be more rooms available on
different days so
that's the best answer I can give you
right now this is the data that we're
stuck with
thank you that helps knowing that there
Mr chairman
representative Mr chairman uh Mr
chairman I was wondering if um you would
prefer us using the hand raise feature
yeah thank you for that representative
Phil I'm just getting used to this
format myself I did see representative
polariski's hand up so why don't we go
with that
um I may still just acknowledge you by
voice but at least I can see who does
the good news is it pops your name to
the top of the
of The rosters so that you can see
I look into that actually as soon as we
get going on our guest speakers I'm
gonna have people shut the blind so we
any other questions because I am having
and seeing none thank you very much
um
I know director balucky from the DMV
she's under a time crunch she has to be
on for 9 30.
good morning I am here can you hear me
okay
good morning director yes I can
perfect I don't know if I'm able to
share video with you I think it's just
audio for us from this perspective
no that's that's fine actually I've
always scheduled about 45 minutes or so
for these introductions I was uh just
hoping to people see a face with a name
and just a little description of what we
um yeah and I should have a couple other
people with me deputy director Michael
Todd should be on and Lieutenant Andy
player from Troop G should also be on
and we are ready whenever you are ready
for us
okay there you go
okay all yours thank you director
Mr chairman and I just want to make sure
that the committee committee has the
slides that we provided to you and Brad
yesterday
hold on one second let's see if we can
Brad is there any way you can get that
up
uh yes I can also um if Dr balucky is
promoted to a panelist she will be able
to share her screen actually Brad could
you do that um with Michael Todd he has
the slides loaded on his computer and he
can share his screen
and while Brad is doing that I'll just
say good morning my name is Elizabeth
pilaki I am the director of the division
of motor vehicles within the department
of safety I have been in my position for
a little over five years now it's hard
to believe it just seems like just a
couple years ago I was in front of the
transportation committee as a newbie and
thank you you were all very gracious and
treated me very well I see a lot of
familiar and unfamiliar faces so I'm
just hoping that we will develop a
really good working relationship I
always encourage all representatives and
Senators as well as any committee
members to reach out to us with any
questions related to the DMV
um
will try our best to help you in any way
and with that we will try to go rather
quickly through our slides I think
they're pretty well
self-explanatory we can stop or slow
down at any point Mr chairman if you see
any questions that come up please feel
free to stop me and we'll we can answer
them as we go along
um I'll just move on to slide number two
and share with you the the mission of
the DMV you can read through the full
version of the of the mission but I
simplify it by saying that our mission
is to ensure the safety of our drivers
the safety of our vehicles and the
safety of New Hampshire roadways moving
on to slide number three
um this is a an org chart of the
Department of Safety so you can see that
we are one of the divisions of the
Department of Safety along with
Administration State Police Homeland
Security fire standards and emergency
services and the division of fire safety
the next slide provides you with an
overview of the DMV and again I won't go
into much detail on this slide because
we'll move into each Bureau and the
following slides
so moving on to slide number five here's
an overview of the of the DMV's Bureau
of operations this is our largest Bureau
and these are the people that are
interacting with our customers face to
face so the the Bureau of operations is
responsible for the processing of any
type of counter transactions we're
Staffing all of our 14 locations we've
listed out both the full-time and
part-time locations we have about 82
full-time employees and 42 part-time
employees within the Bureau of
operations
the Bureau of Licensing these are our
road examiners so these are examiners
that are administering all types of
skill testing for operator licenses
commercial licenses as well as
motorcycle endorsements we have provided
you with just snapshots of numbers so
that you have an idea of what numbers
we're dealing with so at the end of
December of 2020 we had just a little
over 1.1 million active licenses then we
broke those out into CDL licenses
non-driver IDs and real ID compliant
slide number seven introduces our Bureau
of financial responsibility this Bureau
really takes care of anything that ends
up on a Motor Vehicle Record so any
convictions suspensions violations and
so forth
again a snapshot of our calendar year
2020 activities we've processed 57 000
driver license suspensions 27 000
registration suspensions made by mail
tickets these would be tickets that are
coming through all local PDS and we're
actually entering them into our system
manually online ticket pay transactions
29 000 of those were processed and then
not guilty please again manual entry but
we have some good news with that later
slide number eight
um describes the Bureau of registration
I know some of you are familiar with Mr
ayaluna he is no longer with the DMV he
actually moved on to the private sector
so Mr obaden Jeff obedank has taken over
um for Chris and you will have the
pleasure of hearing him later today
our Bureau of registration is
responsible for managing all vehicle
registrations without this within the
state that includes all Motor Vehicles
automobiles boats or any type trailers
or any type of vehicles that are
registered on the road again we're
giving you some statistics at the end of
December of 2020 1.6 million Vehicles
registered this will be again not just
automobiles but any type of vehicles
walking disability plockets 124
000 of those one of my favorites is the
last statistics number of vanity plates
issued 167
slide number nine introduces the Bureau
of title and Anti-Theft
um the Bureau of title manages anything
that has to do with the ownership of the
vehicle they're also involved with a
number of national organizations such as
ncic and nvidis and you see some of
those
transactions down below and those just
really ensure the safety or relate to
any type of crime related to Vehicles so
those would be notifications of stolen
vehicles and others where we have to
conduct a search of our system to see if
any of those ended up in New Hampshire
this is fiscal year 2020 so it's a
little bit different Mike later on we'll
have the statistics for you for a
calendar year 2020 fiscal 2020 would
have ended June 30th of 2020 on 358 000
titles that were issued by the Bureau of
titles and you have the breakdown
slide number 10 discusses the director's
office so this would be my office as
well as the Bureau of audits we really
our role is to oversee the entire
operation and set a strategic priority
for the DMV as well we're responsible
for the oversight of management of all
of our employees 199 full-time employees
the next slide introduces just some
other functions and the first two are
ones that we share with the um with
State Police Troop G driver safety
education so this is your driver's ed
um we have a true court that oversees
all of the schools that educate all of
our 16 year olds and just ensures that
all of the instructors are probably
credentials similarly Pupil
Transportation Lieutenant player has a
trooper in charge of that to oversee a
school bus inspection and certification
of school bus drivers we also provide
motorcycle motorcycle rider safety
education so the motorcycle rider
training courses within the state and
are involved in the National fatal
accident reporting system
slide number 12 just gives you an idea
of all of the different partners and
communities that we are involved with
and communicate with on a regular basis
now I will pause right here because this
is where we transition to Deputy Todd
giving you an overview of just the
effect of the pandemic on DMV operations
but I'll stop and see if there are any
questions Mr chairman
foreign
I'm sorry what was that
representative yes thank you thanks so
much for this very informative
I am interested to know uh how many
vehicles do we have that are operated
and owned by the state
uh State Fleet I don't have those
numbers representative but um I can
definitely get those for you
sure are you looking at all types of
vehicles
I'm sorry are you looking at all types
vehicles or passenger vehicles because
there will be things like snowmobiles
and ATVs that fish and game has
registered as well so
um are you looking at just Motor
Vehicles or all types boats trailers
snowmobiles and so forth
oh I yeah it would be interesting to
know a breakdown thank you
we will get that for you
thank you representative Sykes
yes thank you Mr chairman director
balecki is it possible moving forward
for you to
present to us the total number of decal
plates that have been issued we spend an
awful lot of time on decal plate issues
and I'd be curious to know how many
actual decal plates have been issued
absolutely we can have that statistics I
can I can follow up with the chairman
and provide that to him sometime next
week
yes no no particular Rush thank you
sure a question representative sakes uh
representative Hill
uh yes thank you Mr chairman um nice to
see you again uh director belecki
um I wondered if you could skip back to
I think it was the second slide that you
showed with the total number of
registrations I'd like to take a quick
screenshot
oh under Bureau of registrations is it
this one that
um
actually it was the one that had the
number of licenses issued I think okay
sorry
there you go up that's it perfect
thank you very much for your help and
thank you very much for this uh
yes absolutely my pleasure
representative Hill did you have a
question on this slide
I did not I just wanted to see it again
oh okay and we do it we did make this
presentation available
um again we're okay if the chair wants
to share this with the committee members
four question
directoro thank you Mr chairman thank
you director balecki uh could you
describe um what the difference is
I'm sorry Municipal agent and I I didn't
catch the rest of your question uh an
abode agent you I'm not sure what a
municipal agent is yep um uh you will
very quickly know what it is Municipal
agents are all of our town and City
Clerks that process registrations they
actually are agents of the state because
they own they not only process your town
registration but they also act in an
agency capacity and process the state
portion of the registration as well
uh follow-up Mr chair sure and also um
how does that differ from a boat agent
yep boat agents are typically private or
marinas we do have some of our Municipal
agents that also process boat
registrations and renewals but we've
also brought on a number of boat agents
only which will be privately owned
marinas where you can register your vote
if you don't see any other questions
directly okay if you don't mind we
thought that it would be important for
us to give you an update of really just
how the pandemic has affected DMV
operations and deputy director Michael
Todd can bring you through on these
good morning can everyone hear me okay
yep great thank you very much thank you
to I'd like to thank the committee for
this opportunity
to discuss very briefly how the pandemic
has impacted our operations and how the
DMV has responded
just to give you a quick overview of our
customer demand has it has changed a bit
but you can see that uh in a lot of ways
it hasn't it hasn't uh diminished that
much our customer calls received in 2020
went up to almost a million calls from
about six hundred thousand and twenty of
the year before from 2019 titles issued
and we'll discuss why that is um the
title is issued
it's comparable there was uh it was a
Slowdown in sales and you can see that
with the titles issued that there's a
responsive uh diminishment there but
that is not because we haven't met
demand that's this is just what the
demand is a skills test performed uh
again there's a a bottleneck of if you
will at the driver education programs
and as they're running their uh their
students through we're providing the
skill tests there to them but they're
still you can see we're behind uh the
program is behind the education programs
are behind by about 6 000 in comparison
to last year again though this is this
is what our demand is and we are meeting
the demand
um licenses and ID cards issued at about
300 000
for this year this is what we call a dip
year and um in 2001 RSA 263 10 was
changed to modified
um so that the the anniversary date to
renew your license went from every
fourth year of every fifth year and so
we have a what we call a dip year and
this year's our dick here the last dip
here was 2015 so we gave you the 2015
number so it was a more comparable
number
um you can see that the demand for
licensed system hasn't changed knowledge
tests performed 26 000 and then active
registrations which director Blackie
so the impact of the pandemic on our
operations we did close we did close for
two days to transition to appointment
only walk-in services in March of 2020.
we reopened on that following Monday and
uh in person online in person online and
phone services CDL tests all continue to
be available through that time and they
continue to be available today we did
pause knowledge and Road and motorcycle
tests between March and June you'll
notice our call volume we saw this in
the last slide it increased by up to 300
percent uh during weeks with 6 000 calls
per day that's approximately between
March November we had 50 000 additional
calls per month to make up to get us
that almost million calls last year and
that's because when we transitioned a
lot of our services transitioned to
phone services so people would call we
provide what services were available to
them via the phone they'd have to set up
appointments via the phone and um
we did Leverage a lot of our staff and
put them on the phone systems to respond
to that need we did install an online
appointment
um service that's available so people
can now schedule online you'll see there
are calls
um our calls actually we saw that our
calls did drop down what's what we
normally would expect and you'll see
throughout this presentation that we
have uh We've the pandemic created new
challenges we met those challenges and
then we continue to push the envelope to
push forward to create new efficiencies
for our customers so we did offer six
months extensions for driver licenses
over the phone we still offer those
extensions for individuals who have
particular concerns extenuating
circumstances
automatic extensions for 20-day plates
were available from March to may as real
ID compliance deadline was extended from
to October 2021.
so on the last slide I talked a little
bit about Innovation during the pandemic
took the opportunity here we always
we're always trying to push forward and
make uh provide a better customer
service experience during the pandemic
it wasn't any different we did
we did instill or install a covet health
safety and remote productivity protocol
so essentially no one's coming none of
our staff come to work sick we ask them
a variety of questions we take the
temperature we make sure that we have a
safe and healthy environment in our
buildings and you can see we haven't had
to shut down because of covid what
you've seen in many states around us
where they've had to shut down for
extended periods of time because of
covid it hasn't happened here in New
Hampshire we offer Dropbox Services we
put the online real ID document Checker
I made that available online
applications for motorcycle rider
training in each one of these steps
allows our staff to focus on
transactions on the more essential
transactions to our to our mission and
allows customers customers to be more
efficient with their time and have a
better customer service experience
worker support that's been made
available so so workers who do need to
be out can work from home with uh with
the VPN and laptop
Etc
uh aren't we starting online knowledge
road test request system online taking
payment the online appointment scheduler
became available in October we did see a
a um a drop in our phone cues a
considerable dropping our phone cues and
that's right about that when we saw that
we our phone please go back to what we
we expected pre uh pre-pandemic State
Police have been fantastic troop gians
with the state policeman's been hats
it's fantastic helping with providing
CDL testing so that's continued to be
available and then the online driver's
license renewal update was in December
and the online driver's license
duplicate in January so all these
Services have continued to to provide a
better customer service experience even
during the challenges of the pandemic
allowing us to be custard customer
demand
in comparison to other states we are
doing fantastic I would say we're at the
top of the Heap you can see in
Connecticut they shut down for three
months Maine shut down for 2.5 months
Vermont five months New Hampshire two
days
and so I have a lot of pride in our
state I have a lot of pride in the DMV
and I can have the numbers to back it up
we've done a great job
and
as far as employment availability goes
if it does vary by location but at our
full-time locations licensing
appointments are available one to three
weeks knowledge tests available now to
up to two weeks road test two to six
weeks we do have we do have a longer
wait time for road tests we are putting
more resources toward processing road
and you can see from the customer
comments that the customers are
very much in favor of the appointment
system provides a lot of a lot of
convenience for them and it's it's good
for the DMV it's good for our customers
so it's a win-win all the way around and
you can it's not just the appointment
system though it's not just these these
uh these Innovations online that are
that we're proud of it's our staff
innovation's online are great but they
don't mean as much they don't mean
really much of anything our staff aren't
there to help provide those Services
when they arrive you can see in here
they talk about the stats patient very
well organized very efficient the
Personnel were very helpful and
professional great job it was a surprise
is satisfied with my visit people have
good experiences when they come to the
DMV and it's because of the staff
very thankful for that
so some of the constraints during covid
we do have a 15 percent we did have 15
vacancies and now with waivers we're
down to 13 vacancies it's still a
challenge and then of course absences
you'll see in January and February those
are kind of our high points for absences
in a normal year because it's the flu
season but you'll see every other month
because of the pandemic every month
after uh March we actually exceeded what
we would normally see for our high
number of vacancies for the year so it's
it's a big challenge obviously in April
April and May June or sorry April and
May of uh of last year was a it was a
massive challenge these are all the
constraints we are dealing with but we
are meeting those these um these
this is our current availability of
services we do have our we do have
Milford opening up in mid-February we
also have uh Tamworth available in early
February so we're continuing to expand
and again you can see that even though
we have the challenges of the pandemic
and the challenges of Staffing we are
offering services to our customers with
its customers first we always want to
get to yes for each customer and we're
doing that we're doing that for the best
of our ability and I think we're
succeeding
so the next steps we want to make sure
we're filling our banking positions
continuing to do that increase
employment capacity which you can see
that we're we are um we are able to do
that and we are doing that and then we
want to reopen the Milford and Tamworth
locations for in-person appointments
which what's your plan for for next
month
some online customer service initiatives
this this is a little more detail on
some of the items we've already covered
but you can see in 2020 we delivered in
the online real ID document Checker
motorcycle rider training sign up which
allows our our MRT is a very popular
program allows the applicants to sign up
online and complete the paperwork online
on their own rather than having to have
you know passing paper back and forth
and having to have
additional phone calls with staff so it
frees us up to do other transactions and
allows the customer to get in and out to
get them virtually in and out of their
their transaction very quickly online
ticket payment in August
customer queuing and the Keen substation
in September appointment booking in
October which is a a large deliverable
that really helped improve the customer
experience and also the our the ability
of our staff to return to their normal
duties get them off the phones to get
our transactions flowing and then the
online driver license renewal in
December
and then underway we have the online
driver duplicate
the electronic title leans there's an
RFI out for that right now like
electronic temporary plates electronic
title applications all these all these
new initiatives are again to provide
more convenience for the customer
increase our efficiency and get us
focusing on the transactions and and so
we can turn around the transaction more
quickly and more more convenient for our
customer state to state is obviously a
large deliverable in June and then we
have driver's license image exchange
online motor vehicle records request
both the online calculator online
restoration all this year again we're
not happy with the status quo we're
continually moving forward continuing to
to improve the customer service
experience transaction times and the
convenience
um
so thank you very much I ran through
that very quickly I appreciate your time
I'll turn my time over to the chair and
thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman uh director Todd
thank you very much for this overview a
quick question I have for you with the
appointment schedule how much ahead of
right now we're an individual can make
an appointment
um about 45 days we're uh we're
continually looking at that and seeing
if there needs if that needs to be
increased but right now it seems to be
excuse me thank you um I actually have
two quick questions one is I'm curious
how many customers are
um
participating in the online registration
system as opposed to the call-in
registration system I was unaware that
you guys had launched an online
scheduling service and then second if
you have any information on the actual
in-person turnaround time from start to
finish once a person arrives for their
appointment are you seeing improvements
in that as opposed to the drop-in system
that you've had up to this point thank
you
thank you representative pilerski so
I'll go back to us the customer comments
here you can see one of the customer
comments the individual says they were
in and out in 15 minutes and that is
what the that is what the standard time
is for a transaction you hit the door at
you know and you're out with your
transaction completed in about 15
minutes sometimes 20. so the convenience
to the customers is incredible they
don't have to take as much time off from
work they don't have to you know
whatever whatever it is that they would
normally do during their during their
day they don't have to take time off to
do that
um or much time off to do that they can
come in and be out in 20 minutes so it's
a large convenience for the customer
and as far as the number of people using
the online appointment scheduler it's
it's significant I don't know the exact
figure but I would say it's got to be
more than 80 percent I would say upwards
of 90 are using the online schedule or
schedule their own appointments
thank you those are wonderful
improvements
I have
I'm sorry I wasn't I wasn't able to hear
uh representative Aaron and from here on
it if you've got any questions write
them down we can get the answers later
on
thank you
representative Aaron are you are you
muted
just just barely
um
well I'm interested to know I can hear
thank you
I'm sorry I can't hear the question
could someone relay the question to me
sometimes our others are able to hear
the question that is um okay so I
apologize I wasn't able to hear that and
the audio is not over
um
I'd be happy to take it if you wanted to
uh email it to me or someone could text
message it to me I'd be happy to answer
okay
Mr chairman if there are any other
remaining questions if Brad wants to get
those to me we'll be happy to provide
you with the answers to those I want to
make sure that we give some time to
Lieutenant player because he's really
integral in the DMV Troop G operations
and I know that there's a lot of bills
in front of you that have to deal with
law enforcement matters that the
lieutenant can answer as well
thank you very thank you very much for
your time
thank you very much
chairman if I could ask Brad to allow
Andy player the panelists control as
well he can share his screen and go
through his presentation and we're aware
of the time we'll make it very quick
okay but Brad did you get that uh yes he
good morning thank you I'm uh lieutenant
Andrew Blair with New Hampshire State
Police Troop G I've been the troop
Commander there for approximately three
years now and I've served with uh Troop
G for uh almost nine years
uh trip to definitely works very closely
with the DMV uh the New Hampshire State
Police mission statement there is in
front of you and you can see that we are
dedicated to maintaining the highest
degree of law enforcement service
throughout the state of New Hampshire
while maintaining the traditions of
fairness professionals integrity that's
something that we pick take to hard as
troopers and we know it from the day
that we come on
um the state police as a whole is
typically comprised of 340 Troopers
we're down approximately 30 Troopers as
of today uh due to uh due to retirements
and uh some budgeting with covid trying
to uh anticipate vegetarian shortfalls
right now we're down about 30 Troopers
the division as a whole is made up of
seven troops in addition to
investigative and Specialty units and
our jurisdiction actually is derived
from RSA 106 B colon 12. uh there's a
quick visual on the side that shows the
breakdown of the different troops as you
can see troop G's in the purple and we
actually covered the entire state
we're a little bit different than uh a
lot of the other troops uh our mission
is different where we're not covering a
particular Road or a particular town or
County doing what's considered normal
police work where a non-traditional law
enforcement entity of the State Police
uh we're actually our Barracks is
located within the Division of Motor
Vehicles building in Concord uh it works
very well for us because it just allows
for a much uh better flow of
communication between our two
organizations there's actually three
primary sections of Troop G the
commercial Motor Vehicle Enforcement
unit
the field enforcement unit and the DMV
task force and uh
what we do is we really govern the
administrative laws and rules governing
safety inspections sale of vehicles as
well as Federal commercial uh or as well
as federal regulations governing
commercial motor vehicles and then
there's a number of other tasks that we
do to assist the Division of Motor
Vehicles
uh so what makes us different is we're
we're slated to have 47 Troopers uh as
well as two auxiliary Troopers which are
our part-time Troopers are actually
retired from the state police and came
back to assist with our mission and then
we have 12 civilians I will tell you
right now due to uh due to some of the
the stuff that's going on we're down
seven Troopers as of today uh and we've
have we've had a few other folks that
are uh temporarily assigned elsewhere
within the division to try and meet
demands that the organization is facing
we have a number of uh daily
responsibilities uh as I said we cover
the entire State we work with a number
of different entities from The
commission's Office Division Motor
Vehicles Department of Transportation
federal motor care Association uh
Federal Highway and a lot of uh the
represent representatives and
organizations that represent those
industries that we govern
uh the field enforcement unit is uh
primarily monitors and audits the
approximately 4 200 dealer and
inspection stations throughout the state
of New Hampshire uh to make sure that
they are complying with administrative
rules and laws that govern state
inspections and vehicle sales uh we have
staff that goes out for any new
dealership that opens as well as collect
supplies for dealerships and inspection
stations when they close
we also assist with the estate mechanic
inspection certification program so all
the mechanics that actually conduct the
state inspections we host a uh
information session for them we
presented that and then we actually go
out and do field tests of each mechanic
we locate and serve those that are are
deemed to be habitual offenders and need
a noted need a hearing for for that
process to commence we also prosecute
and participate in court and as well as
administrative actions for Law and Rule
violations against vehicle dealers and
inspection stations uh we conduct
Salvage inspections of vehicles that
have been deemed a total loss by the
insurance companies
um when those vehicles are repaired and
placed back on the roadway we do an
inspection of those to make sure there's
not fraud and that the vehicles are uh
are put together in a safe fashion
uh we also review Vehicles seeking New
Hampshire state issued bins as well as
enforcement involves State and criminal
Motor Vehicle Laws and then in addition
we also make sure to assist local police
departments that need assistance in
these areas of assistance as well right
these types of Investigations
uh in addition we have an investigations
unit that's actually located on the
second floor of the Division of Motor
Vehicles they are uh it's it's supposed
to be staffed by a detective sergeant
and Three Investigators again we have
some staff that is uh temporarily
assigned elsewhere so we are down on on
some of those that staff as well
um but they are primarily responsible
for investigating title fraud uh
internal fraud that occurs at the
Division of Motor Vehicles unfortunately
we don't see very much of that at all so
that's a good thing uh we do license and
registration fraud residency fraud and
identity fraud we do see a fair amount
of the identity fraud
um that does that people do attempt to
uh perform in New Hampshire
um we also provide assistance with law
enforcement with these types of
Investigations including vehicle title
uh the driver education unit they
provide the oversight and support for
the more than 75 driver education
schools
um and oversight and support for the 250
driver education instructors they work
with the curriculum as well as
instructor certification and
professional development approval and
secondary school approval
we have uh one trooper that actually is
dedicated to that particular program
we have another Trooper that's dedicated
to the people Transportation unit uh
that's that's response for overseeing
the school bus industry in New Hampshire
uh they monitor an audit a hundred
public school bus companies for
compliance with the administrative rules
for school board School Bus
Transportation uh they conduct criminal
and motor vehicle background checks of
the bus drivers they uh are responsible
for training and certification of school
bus drivers and school bus driver
instructors they oversee safety
inspections of more than 3 000 school
buses in New Hampshire and assist with
investigations of school bus crashes in
addition they'll investigate complaints
regarding school buses and school bus
drivers and they also assist at the
state Emergency Operations Center uh if
there is a event that requires a mass
evacuation and school buses are needed
to do that the trooper in that
particular unit helps assist with that
that at the EOC and again we assist the
local police departments with in matters
involving school buses
the commercial Motor Vehicle Enforcement
unit that enforces state and federal
regulations regarding commercial Motor
Vehicles as they pertain to
transportation of persons or Goods
including hazardous materials
Troopers are certified to conduct uh
commercial motor vehicle inspections in
compliance with the Federal Motor
Carrier safety administration Troop G is
the only uh only group in lawn New
Hampshire law enforcement that is
certified to do motor carrier
inspections uh under the FMCSA in New
Hampshire
um we enforce rules and laws pertaining
to the international registration plan
uh International fuel tax agreement as
well as a unified carrier registration
um they're we're also trained and
equipped to determine compliance with
the state size and weight loss and we
also educate and audit new motor
carriers so if a brand new trucking
company uh enrolls with the the Federal
Motor Carrier safety administration uh
they're based out of New Hampshire we'll
go and conduct an audit to make sure
they're in compliance and help educate
them how they can remain in compliance
as they uh as they become a new new
carrier we also assist the division of
motor vehicles with a commercial
driver's license testing and assist
police agencies with crashes involving
commercial motor carriers and uh we also
not surprisingly commercial Motor
Vehicle Enforcement
uh The Authority for the the commercial
Motor Vehicle Enforcement actually comes
from RSA 266 72-a paragraph b
um paragraph five the inspections
Encompass the vehicle components the
driver's fiscal physical condition cargo
condition and documentation so to make
sure they have uh the proper licensing
that they are complying with hours of
service uh Troopers actually have the
authority to place drivers and vehicles
out of service uh for specifically
defined violations of adopted Federal
Regulations the inspections are then
uploaded once they're complete into a
database which is available to law
enforcement throughout the country
almost immediately and those inspections
are actually used to build a company
safety profile so if a carrier has a
inspection where there's no violations
found their safety rating goes up
whereas if you go and conduct an
inspection and numerous violations are
found that could negatively impact us
carrier safety profile
it's kind of a quick rundown there's a
lot that we do but I'm open to any
questions if uh if any of the committee
members have any thank you
thank you sir
happens
Mr chairman uh just uh director be lucky
again I just I just in closing I just
wanna again
um invite any committee members to reach
out to us with any questions even if
you're not sure if you're reaching out
to the right person we can ensure that
we route you to where you need to go
I'll share with Brad our email addresses
and Office phone numbers
um I think those email lists usually the
quickest and easiest way to reach us and
again if there are any questions that
you think of after the presentation feel
free to reach out to us and we really
appreciate your time and looking forward
to working with all of you this session
thank you very much director thank you
very much everybody else
um I do appreciate it I'm sure we'll
have plenty of questions for you in the
future
thank you again
so now
um let's see
I have actually asked the presentations
to be about 10-15 minutes just a summary
of that information probably didn't get
out so that's my fault
I want to face with a public Hearing in
15 minutes
I allowed a DMV to go through their
whole presentation because they in fact
deal with them probably 80 of the time
well with Department of Safety
uh but in terms of the Department of
Transportation
I don't know I wouldn't mind
rescheduling it can we get them on to
see if a rescheduling would be okay with
them
Rodriguez
yes good morning I'm hearing
commissioner Sheehan is here as well and
she would be best to speak thank you
yeah I just saw you know
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee
we really defer to um to you we're happy
to keep our remarks brief this morning
or to reschedule so there's more time to
go through our materials
um if you don't mind and I do apologize
um I'd really like to get the full
presentation
and I'm looking at 15 minutes would it
be okay what do we reschedule rather
than try to abbreviate it that much
that's quite all right um we recognize
that you might have questions as well so
we'd rather not be rushed and make sure
we address everything that the committee
might want us to cover
I'm gonna ask uh Captain Eastman the
yes hello good morning uh that would be
completely fine I have no problem with
rescheduling
but I certainly appreciate it thank you
very much
can you be in touch shortly
I only had one other person who like who
promised me was only going to take two
minutes
so we have two minutes
yes good morning Mr Jeremy can you hear
me
okay
all right um good morning uh chairman
Washington members of house
Transportation committee it's nice to
see some familiar faces and some new
faces
um I will be brief
um I don't know what's worse to be the
last speaker before lunch or the for or
your first hearing so I'll go through as
quick as I can
um my name is Dan Bennett I'm the vice
president of government relations for
the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association
I did send you all a fact sheet
yesterday with my contact information
and also some info to speed up this uh
introduction so nhada is a trade group
that represents the motor vehicle
industry we are over 500 businesses that
are car trucks snowmobile ATV
construction farm equipment
um and body shops in all corners of the
state in every Community uh we have
about 14 000 employees and make up about
a quarter of the retail sales uh in New
Hampshire and we are both franchise and
independent members we actually have
more independent businesses than um
franchise members so two important
things about nhada is that a Cornerstone
issue for us is roadway safety we
believe in safe roads a safe motoring
public through things like the annual
inspection program the ban on texting
while driving motorcycle rider education
and the traffic safety Commission of
which we're a member and I know you'll
have a bill on later in the the session
um another important program we run is
an autocap program which is a Consumer
complaint program and I point this out
because if you have a constituent that
calls our autocap program can certainly
help you a lot of times complaints
against dealers or inspection stations
is really just miscommunication or
misinformation they didn't know what
tires for Life meant or the salesman
didn't know salesperson didn't know they
wanted two names on the title uh not one
in which order they should be in so we
can help mediate those
um those confusions or conflicts that
come up it's an independent panel the
results are binding on the dealer
they're not on the consumer and if the
dealer doesn't abide by the decision we
have the option to throw them out of our
association they lose their health care
benefits the workers comp benefits uh
things like that so the Attorney General
sends about 200 um cases a year over to
us so I think it shows their confidence
in our resolutions system so that
information can be handy if you have
um
uh constituent issues so throughout the
session you'll hear from from me from us
uh from our possibly our president Pete
McNamara and then uh many of our members
who really are the true experts who are
in the field who are in the trenches uh
doing this every day uh you'll hear from
us on a variety of bills
um especially HB 522 which will modify
the or propose to modify the annual
inspection program uh we currently have
an over 15 percent failure rate with an
annual program so extending that in our
opinion is something
um that's a just an unsafe change in
policy
um I was pleased to see the presentation
by the DMV and dos we are partners with
them and we were very very closely
um I would like to give some kudos to
director bialeki
um and and uh Michael Todd as well and
their team
um their operations during during covid
were unparalleled uh you saw that when
they mentioned that uh they were the
only DMV around
um to have a only a two-day shutdown so
they really deserve a tremendous amount
of kudos for the businesses and the
citizens of the state
um you know during the original uh
shutdown vehicle sales and service were
deemed by the governor to be essential
services so our workload
um and our needs at the DMV never shut
that slowed down whether it was for
title turnaround the buying and selling
of operations of businesses inspections
and things like that they handled it in
a highly efficient manner
um and shifted when they needed to
um
I I'd like to point to we had an
out-of-state dealer come into New
Hampshire and buy a large truck
dealership uh two of them actually
um and at the conclusion of it in the
meeting with the DMV the comment by this
out-of-state dealer was I wish all New
England DMVs operated the way New
Hampshire did so uh again I point that
out and a kudos to them and their their
operations and their team
um we and I look forward to working with
you over the session uh if there's
anything that I can answer or assist
with please don't hesitate to let me
know as mentioned I sent you my contact
information
um and I'll answer any questions if
there are any um and if not good luck
with the rest of your hearings um and
and your workload today
so
yeah I just have one question
uh two and a half
yeah just kidding uh any other questions
from the committee
don't see any so thank you very much
again Dan Bennett uh we'll see you soon
so what's up okay
um I apologize again for the confusion
and in the communication gap but that's
okay we can reschedule the other two
speakers at a later time probably just
zoom rather than trying to schedule
another day in this room
um I figured it would be only fair so
they could go through their whole
routine
in the meantime we've got a public
hearing our first one of the year in
about
eight minutes according to this clock
so why don't anybody go on mute take a
break for a couple of minutes stretch
your legs and I'll see you at uh just
foreign
please
yes Vice chair Larry I'll be I'll be
Larry when all this is over
anybody cranky about how cold it is
besides me
it's freezing
okay we all ready
okay
the public hearing from House Bill one
five nine FM on that relative to
organizations authorization decals for
multi-use decal number of plates
uh
representative Jordan Ellery is the
brand sponsor let me see if I can get
him on to introduce
good morning how are you guys besides
are you ready to start Mr chair awesome
for the record my name is Jordan
ulery of Hillsboro 37 I'm introducing
this bill on behalf of the Knights of
Columbus
uh it passed last year unanimously I
sent you guys all an email
um with the picture of the emblem of the
order which would be the decal applied
to the plates uh for the Knights of
Columbus the money for this uh raised
from selling these decals to our members
and members only or our members families
would go to the Nephrology program at
Dartmouth Hitchcock which the Knights of
Columbus have supported for decades now
um previously we supported people on
dialysis with their unpaid uh
secondary expenses you know like things
like
antacids and some medicines that weren't
covered for Indigent people and we're
extending this to uh kidney transplants
so
we need to raise a little bit more money
and this was one way we could do it
I can't hear you
down here scroll down
I see oh I see one representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman representative
early just to cover our bases
um
one of the requirements of this bill is
the tax status of an organization could
you just remind me what the tax status
is of the Knights of Columbus Knights of
yeah just if anybody have to speak as
representative said this didn't pass
unanimously on the committee last year
it didn't uh go through the house I
believe it was on consent it should have
been like
um and unfortunately he went to the
Senate at the cross over again that's
when covid-19 struck so if you remember
for those of you here those that were
new what the Senate did
um you know in that circumstance they
just picked the bills they thought had a
yet most important created the Omnibus
bills uh in that group we dealt with for
the rest of the session unfortunately
this one didn't make it and that's why
it's been reintroduced
um but it's also why I picked it for the
first one of the year I figured it would
be an easier so
any other questions for the committee
representative
thank you Mr chair this actually is just
an inquiry for you
um but also we'll come across it in the
next hearing when we discuss the request
from the Masons they both state on the
bill that uh on line three that they'll
be number 16 of organizations added to
the list
um obviously if we approve both of these
as written they would contradict each
other is that something that will
automatically be taken care of or would
we need to amend one of them to change
one of them to 17 on the list
it's a good pickup I would suspect that
could be corrected but I will double
check before we execute and if we do
need to get the amendment I chose is one
available
thank you for the typo category to me
and they can usually fix things like
that when the bills are enrolled
sure
do you have uh the blue sheet as to how
uh you know what we haven't closed which
is good um that's the only person I had
signed up to speak uh for the bill which
was the French sponsor representative
ulrey uh before I read off the other
people that have
listed their position is there anybody
not Memories no okay uh the only other
people that signed up were you used to
call the blue sheet is uh Bob Dunn
um Roman Catholic bishop of Manchester
he's representing in Eric Rathbun uh
just a member of the public and both of
them
um actually
I've done supports the bill and Eric
Rathbun is opposed but he did not sign
up this week and that's all I have for
this one
so on that I'm going to close the public
hearing on 159 and uh our next one is
okay
foreign
[Music]
see
fantastic
okay
um you can open the public hearing on
Bill 451 FM
connect allowing the New Hampshire
Masons to issue decals for motor vehicle
plates
and hold on a few minutes we gotta
I mean don't I don't see anybody who
signed up to speak online yet
if you don't get online then I'll
would you go ahead
I'm sure thank you Mr chairman
if you all can hear me
uh this house bill 451 FN allowing New
Hampshire Nations to issue the accounts
for motor vehicle plates
this bill permits the Grand Lodge of
ancient free and accepted masons in New
Hampshire to issue decals for multi-use
plates
very similar to the last bill
um again this past last year
believe unanimously on consent and off
to the Senate once again it didn't rise
to the level of importance to make it to
a senate on the west bill due to covet
19. so it's been reintroduced
um
to representative Pulaski I was looking
at this after
well during the break you know it's a
good catch
and still confirm it but I would imagine
that OLS would have to put the next line
available on both of these bills not
knowing that one or the other may not
make it so 99 certain that'll be taken
care of an enrolled bills and I will
double check
with an observation
um any questions from the committee
um 451.
sorry sorry I couldn't hear you
um just double checking and clarifying
this was exactly the same situation as
our previous bill that it went through
the house um on the consent calendar
also
yes that's correct thank you I just
wanted
to consent but it did pass the house
maybe we didn't want people to make it
so I had to replace a chair introduce
the bill for you okay are you here if
you'd like to speak to it
um
because sit here
you're not me or Mike it may not be a
lot of your life
well this is getting complicated yes it
is
I'm not sure that's what I'd call them
Larry but
uh
honestly I don't even want what's
51. okay thank you well uh as I'm sure
you've explained this is a bill we put
in last year just allows
uh for the decals for Miss Sonic
to be on the plate it passed last year I
think it came in actually if I remember
correctly
and then it can hung up over in the
Senate with the uh when we went into
covert lockdown
so I would just ask that this committee
once again unanimously approves it
sends it on its way
so that uh
all the Masons in New Hampshire if they
choose
you can have the Masonic emblem on the
flight
thanks
yes thank you Mr chairman my question
would be for uh speaker Packard I I
asked the previous bills Prime sponsor
what their tax exempt status was just to
make sure we covered that base and I
would ask the same question of you
uh it's a 501 feet
I'm sorry
the private room C10
thank you sir it's the uh one of the
ones that we added for internal
organizations
uh a Metro of the class session of the
session before
that's good thank you so much sir
okay how would anybody else that's not
enlisted here that's the
actually 415 one
just to say no no no no
uh would anybody else with the public
like to speak that's everybody I have on
very excuse me
thank you I'm sorry Mr chair um I just
wanted to point out that representative
Cleaver is stuck as an attendee and
needs to be promoted
um to a panelist thank you
okay thank you is that something you can
do representative
thank you
Laura thank you speaker back I see no
other questions
me and no other people to speak in terms
of the blue sheep
um representative Albury
Barry supports
and the member of the public Eric
wrapman who also opposed the last bill
opposes this one as well
[Music]
Bill 451 uh the next hearing is at 11 30
foreign
absolutely
all right welcome back everybody uh
looking up the public hearing on House
Bill 361 do not pull up the world star
there's been a brand
with my Prime sponsor
yeah we can get him cheat up
here can you hear me representative
Graham
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
I'm representative John Graham
I represent Hillsboro district 7 which
is the town of Bedford
I bring this bill forward
in order to give some
honor to those family Matt family
members who have lost a service member
in uh defense of our nation what it
would do is wave the ten dollar fee for
the gold star decal that is placed on
plates
the overall economic impact of this is
minuscule since the law was passed we've
sold I think it is nine uh sets of
decals at ten dollars each
um
and the department will testify after me
talking about the fact that they feel
that they can absorb this relatively
minor
um
expense and I think that it is the right
way to go that we honor these families
who have who have suffered and I would
ask that you ought to pass on House Bill
what's the number what's the number of
this one
361. thank you I'm glad to see one
committee's on time today anyways
I'm getting
thank you Mr chairman
um
represent Graham
can you hear me I hear you
thank you listen it says in uh line two
paragraph three or section three
Department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services etc etc issue the cows
veterans who qualify under this chapter
and shall collect a fee of ten dollars
for the set of the cows but you stated
that they would waive that ten dollar
um let me pull it up I don't have it in
front of me
um one of the disadvantages of zoom and
not getting copies of bills
um where it where we are talking
difference is that there are decals for
various
um
affiliations with for example the army
or the Marine Corps what it is if you
look in the Bold part in section Roman 3
the division of Veterans Services shall
provide Gold Star Family decals to those
who qualify under the RSA free of charge
that is the change to the existing law
representative patero
thank you Mr chair uh representative
Graham
um do you happen to know how long
um Gold Star Family decals have um been
allowed
um it's been a couple of years I think
the department will be able to testify
that I do know that they bought a roll
of decals in 2019 and still have most of
them left
representative
thank you Mr chairman
uh representative Graham
it am I missing where it specifies
who actually qualifies
um is it a parent is it a a widow is it
a discipline
it is specified in the RSA and I do not
I'm not
memorizing that RSA nor do I have it in
front of me but if you look under the
RSA it specifies who gold star families
uh representative Graham thank you for
taking my question
um
would you have any idea or is this a
better question for the people coming
after you
um do we have ideas of total numbers of
gold star applicants that could result
from this
um I do not they may but not all gold
star family members want to
place those decals on their their
license plate only because of the grief
that they still feel
um so I there's no way that I can answer
that nor do I think the department will
they may have a total number
um but if we go back far enough it's a
larger number but it's still in my
opinion worth the
um States in essence subsidizing these
decals for those family members who do
wish to to
thank you for your response and thank
any other questions for representative
Graham
thanks those things
[Music]
yes if you indulge me Mr
chairman Walsh in answer to
representative tolerski's question about
the eligibility
um
I have that in front of me it's
it's a rather long list but it says
family members would include spouse
grandfather grandmother
father step father adoptive mother
adopted father son daughter stepson
stepdaughter adoptive son adoptive
daughter brother sister half brother
half-sister stepbrother and stepsister
this list was revised back in 20 in 2020
previous and previous work that we had
done and it's under
261-c colon 3 Dash small a
if that's helpful
I was in the cooking process of looking
it up myself thinking representative
sites in terms of answering the question
um
[Music]
you want a lot better at that than I at
this point so no other questions from
representative
thank you representative Graham uh thank
you Mr chairman and I do hope that the
committee Finds Its way to move this off
[Music]
I'm coming green
sorry Mr chairman it took me just a
second to get myself unmuted there on
the zoom call
um thank you very much for allowing me
to have some testimony today
um for the record my name is Kevin Grady
uh I am a resident of Hooksett where
I've lived for the last 22 years uh
prior to that I spent 25 years on active
duty in our air force uh traveling
around the world today I'm here
representing the 19-member organizations
of the state veterans advisory committee
and these hopefully are uh that our our
Representatives our veteran service
organizations are uh we're chartered by
state RSA
115-a-da colon 8 to speak for the
veteran community and those groups are
our names that would be familiar to you
for our new members things like the
American Legion the Veterans of Foreign
Wars the Air Force Association which I
represent the National Guard Association
of the United States those kinds of of
groups are represented here and one of
the things we do is we look at all the
bills that are coming out
and we take a position in favor of or
against them and then they send me
normally to see you folks in person and
I look forward to being able to do that
at some point uh but at least to testify
and let you know uh how we're thinking
on this to just clarify this the the the
actual a very very brief history lesson
we understand as veterans how difficult
the system is with with respect to
license plates I know Massachusetts has
a group of license plates and every time
somebody sees a Massachusetts license
plate that that appeals to their
particular demographic they're coming in
front of your committee looking to try
and get a plate that says this and we
know how expensive that those are so
about five or six years ago we came up
with this idea of a of a kind of a
standard plate that you could put a
decal on and and we have taken as our
position in the in the state veterans
advisory committee uh for if you want a
a decal that says when I was in the Air
Force I got an Air Force accommodation
medal you can have that but it's going
to be a sticker okay it's not going to
be a full-fledged license plate
um this the the the the the bill two
years ago that established this was HB
549 and it's in RSA
261c for those of you that might want to
go and and look up the eligibility and
all that it was out of the 2019 uh
session we as a state veterans advisory
committee met on this last January in
January earlier this month and we
unanimously support this bill we
understand that
um you know that when when one of us
serves as a as as a military person the
whole family serves and the the more
visibility that we get of the sacrifices
that are made not just by our service
members but by their families uh who are
left back home even for the ones that
return uh the more the more we like that
so we unanimously support this and with
that uh I have any questions I will
leave you with the idea that if you are
thinking of introducing a bill that has
veteran impact we invite you to come and
use us as a resource and you can come
speak at our our monthly meetings and
tell us about why it is that you want to
introduce what you're introducing so
with that Mr chairman I'll yield the
floor back to you as subject to any
questions anybody has
thank you sir
next up speaking in support of the bill
you know Warren Perry
um staff from the Department of military
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the transportation committee for the
record my name is Warren Perry I am the
deputy adjutant general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services our
division of veteran services uh manages
the decal program uh for veterans plates
and Veterans decals
uh we uh we are very much in favor of uh
this bill uh it is uh not cost
prohibitive at all the stickers cost
about two dollars a piece
and we're able to absorb that cost with
the sale of the other decals that
representative Graham mentioned you know
based on service and for Medals of Valor
uh right now uh I will tell you that we
have sold to confirm what Mr
representative Graham said we have sold
uh since 2019 uh nine sets of decals
most recently to Captain phaneuf's
family uh some of you may remember that
Captain phano tragically died in a
airplane crash in Afghanistan uh
uh about a year ago so this what this
program does is just it just allows us
to give the decals instead of charging a
this menial 10 fee to families who have
lost a loved one in the defense of our
nation
so subject to any questions you might
have I will uh I will yield to questions
I've seen none thank you sir
thank you very much for your time
uh that's all the people I have signed
up this week
I'll put it out to the public in case
there's any late new people joining but
is there anybody else that we should
speak on this bill
foreign
[Music]
um
in terms of the blue sheet there was
only one other person that signed up for
this bill heard his name into the last
couple Eric Rathburn member of the
public uh Annie is in support of this
particular event so
with that being said
um
does anybody else has anything on this
let me give you a before I close it
completely
oh yeah
and I think George could probably attest
to this we did the best we're not going
to do the best they can to schedule
appropriate times for these hearings it
seems like uh you can never win on them
originally I looked at maybe doing some
executive sessions uh that's why I
didn't shorten up the first couple of
bills I figured those would be short
and I've also left a little bit of time
this afternoon originally thinking we
could exec
the reason
um
being that the health clerk everybody
else involved would really like to see
us merge all the plate bills that we're
in support of by Amendment so just give
one plate Bill coming out of here it's
going to simplify everybody simplify
save a lot of time having my own
questions on a couple of these and I did
not want to waste ols's time with a
couple of versions
um until we had these hearings today
that's why there's a little bit of extra
time built in here we'll do a little bit
better next week and you'll see you next
week at the last hearings at 2 15 and
we'll be definitely doing an exact
session
at the inside I want to close the public
hearing on health bill 361.
yeah if I'm not mistaken
we're going to have a couple of lunch
break
and our next one is those Bill 222 at
[Applause]
[Music]
it does sound like
um representative I was trying to speak
but there it sounds like there is some
background noise
Mr chairman are you there this is uh
I uh I wondered did I understand you
correctly that we will not be executing
any bills today
correct it was my original plan uh but
again I didn't want to waste ols's time
terrific thank you very much that makes
foreign
good afternoon everybody
hopefully you can hear me let me raise a
hand if you can
um
public hearing open on House Bill 222 FM
authorizing to hear from municipalities
for some details from motor vehicle
plates in Municipal officers
Belanger
I'm getting another minute or two maybe
if he doesn't appear I'll get a
volunteer at University
actually do we see anybody on the list
representative Roy
he's not testifying okay
so you're the only one to testify it I'd
never judge this I think we'd have much
yep
representative
yes
um a couple of uh people have testified
that they have sent things in via email
is there a
is that something that everyone else has
received because I have not and I was
wondering if um
there's something I need to check up on
to see that um
email it sent to the entire committee uh
where that would show up
have you received anything from
Transportation or Transportation related
not from testimony from anyone
president
what are the things I wanted to do
before we close today and find out
anybody well I guess we can do that
while we wait for representative plan
sure I'll give them a minute uh is
anybody else not I sent out two or three
emails myself using the link through the
general quarter
um raise your hands if you have not been
they're not zoom related but like
documents I sent out a few emails just
keeping the committee apprised and now
I'm finding out some aren't getting it
and I've been using the uh the link
through the general court so I want to
talk to the point for me to get that
fixed yeah
yeah
okay
has everybody else been getting the
emails yeah
yeah I have not
[Music]
um
I'll make sure everybody receives that
and put it into my clerk step here so
but I think those people who said
another reason possibly could be whether
or not it's on the legislative email or
if using personals anyway I'm not
recognize we've got an issue let me get
to the bottom of it we're not going to
um exactly anything today anyway so I'll
make sure you get the information before
that happens next week okay
but that being said let's get to
representative Lander
can everybody hear me okay
yeah thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
transportation committee I appreciate
you taking my time and I apologize I did
receive an email through my legislative
email that says it got postponed until
next week so I apologize for the
confusion
thank you for hearing my testimony today
on this bill today I come before you
sort of through Zoom
in regards to my house bill relative to
municipally elected decal plates
so
everybody loves their plates here in New
Hampshire
um unfortunately we don't have plates
like other states but one of the many
benefits that we do have are the decal
plates which I think are an excellent
addition to our state it brings in
additional revenue and it brings in
um well that's it I mean it just brings
in additional Revenue so HB 20 222
is specific to municipally elected
leaders in our communities
it gives them a decale no I have not
spoken with the Department of
Transportation on this matter yet and I
do apologize I was planning on doing
that today once I realized uh that the
committee had what it looked like the
committee had postponed but did not
um
so
um it just forgives our Municipal
Municipal budget committees uh Selectmen
school boards and opportunity school
board members excuse me an opportunity
to have a detailed plate and a vanity
plate and
um actually I've got a couple on this
one
we needed by some of the new members
know where this
came to be
two turns back
already for a couple of years before we
because for years maybe even decades
you're right people around the state
wanted some personalization on their
license plates
and every time we got a bill to propose
any specific license plate we had to say
no because of the sheer numbers
thousands and thousands of dollars
so this was a solution and for the most
part if you look into your RSA which is
261 B3
we'll see that
the full intent of this beginning was to
give legitimate non-profit organizations
the ability to get this decal plate if
you go through the DNB or a small fee it
has the real estate or an approved
sticker or decal provided by that
organization
the exception that I can find a statute
to that
is
the fire department
which if you look
and I have a way to answer my question
sir
um
except for decals issue by the city of
town Financial to Firefighters and
retired firefighters decals shovel
distributed by organizations authorized
by Statute so in other words what I'm
saying is that the only exception to
this chapter is the firefighters and
many specifically having method of
getting the stickers with decals which
is from the fire chief to the
firefighters
and it is their universal symbol which
never goes away
so my first question on this
is
to see something missing here if this
would have been passed the way it is who
in the municipality is going to be
authorized to combine these decals and
uh thank you representative for your
question I appreciate it um that's a
really good question so
um for myself when I was a former UNH
student I had obtained a decal and
um I obtained that detail
um by uh
the excuse me the town clerk's office
um I filed some paperwork the town clerk
would then send me send the information
and UNH would then send that detail to
me
um
uh at a later date and then I would also
receive the vanity plate as well
um so
while you bring about valid question I
assumed that it would be the town clerk
that would provide that decal plate just
as that town clerk also provides that
um
that vanity plate that's exactly what
this is this is a vanity plate
um
I believe I answered your question
sometimes I'm actually surprised that
probably certain sort of deals
um okay so I'll leave that one load at
this point my next question would be
um
Rich officers of the municipalities
what's considered an officer let's give
you an example I mean I can assume that
the elected uh chair of a select board
for example is an officer but my town
um Vice chair um
planning but that's an appointed
position would that be considered an
officer
well what do you think
so this is supposed to be for
municipally elected officials
so it obtains so it applies to all
um
the the question of officers over
officials would be a question that I
would need to ask OLS and I'd be happy
to make that Amendment if it's necessary
um but it it is and it is meant to be
for municipally elected officials
um and that applies to all members of
the budget committee all members of the
board of Selectmen all members of the
school board planning board provide
provide upon showing of proof of office
um so you obviously receive you you do
have taken oath upon taking office I did
when I became a selectman
um as we all did when we all became
state representatives uh that is your
proof your oath of office you provide
that proof you attend that detail for
your plate
and it's a generic municipally elected
decal
um not you know you don't there's not
one for Budget committee there's not one
for selectman there's not one for school
board it's just one generic for
municipally elected official
okay that was another question so you
see me there
um finally my last question would be on
it
what would happen once uh
officer
who's no longer an officer what happens
to that decaf
but the ability to have that detail on
the plate
no I should just because
you can assume a lot of things but
unless it's freaking announcements I'm
not sure
what to do
no I mean that's a valid point
representative and thank you um
I I appreciate it that you know again an
amendment that I'd be happy to make
um
absolutely
all right I'm just again I'm just asking
questions to say the decal plate though
is not always that simple especially
form
101 the organizations
does change in a pretty good-sized way
the intent of the program to begin with
so done with me any other questions from
the committee okay I see several
representative
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
representative Belanger for your your
your bill here question I have if I'm
reading this correctly are the decals at
no charge
oh
uh no representative Gorski that is not
the intent um it is uh supposed to be uh
paid for of a set amount I Believe by
Dot
I would have to get back to you on that
and I do apologize
um but uh you know for your typical
decal plate say for the ones from UNH
um I paid 15 or 25 and
um that went to the UNH Foundation
however that would be so the the reason
why this has a fiscal note is my
understanding is because it will cost
but it actually brings in more Revenue
so
um
no it is not going to be free of charge
you do have to it you do pay for the
vanity plate and then you would also uh
pay for the decal as well
okay thank you very much
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um so
first I would ask you to specify where
would the profits of this program go
that's not
so my intent is for the funds to go into
the general fund
okay thank you follow up
follow up
um the other problem I see though is
that this is listed in the specific
section
um RSA
261-b colon 9 which lists the
non-profit organizations that are
approved for this program
um I don't actually think if this was an
approved use of the decal program it
should go here in this section of
non-profits
um
could you suggest where else it could go
or have you looked at this section any
closer
uh yes uh representative thank you I
appreciate your question um so when OLS
had given me the decal plate
um excuse me the decal plate
uh bill I did research the bill
previously I thought it was sufficient
but again being a new representative I'm
not trying to say that that's my excuse
but
um
sometimes you know you get lost in in
the legal mumbo jumbo so I do apologize
I I understand that in 261 colon excuse
me 261-b colon 3 authorized
organizations
it
it it seems vague doesn't seem specific
I guess you could create a different
section
um say
there's uh 261-b colon 3-c uh you could
do Dash D if you will
um
yeah
that answers my question I just wanted
to point out that it's not technically a
non-profit so I believe that if we keep
it as it is in the wrong section but
that answers my question thank you
thank you representative
representative
thank you Mr chair and I hope you can
hear me can you hear me all right
yes ma'am I can
thank you uh and thank you for taking my
question
um normally we have
um elections for these officials around
town meeting day and if the elected
official is either not re-elected or
doesn't choose to run again what happens
with the decal are they require to take
them off or return them or what do you
want to do with that
so as I stated to the first gentleman's
question representative Aaron thank you
um the the once the officer has no
longer continued that office they would
be required to
um no longer be allowed to hold that
decal as they no longer are an elected
official and again an amendment that
would need to be made
yeah thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative
um representative Aaron I I think stole
some of my thunder there
um so it is not your expectation that
these are lifetime
stickers that uh no that if if you had
been a selectman ever you could uh you
could maintain that uh that status on
your license plate
no this would be strictly for those who
are elected to office once you have been
removed from office whether it be you
resign uh you've been removed via Vote
or you choose not to run you would no
longer be allowed to hold that plate
you could hold the vanity plate if you
wanted to but you would not be able to
have the detail itself
um my my follow-up would be
um have you considered how it would work
with
um groups like uh Cooperative school
districts
um in in what would it be issued by
um a particular town or could it come
from any Town
um for any of the people that were that
that participate on any of the school
boards or the budget Committees of the
school boards as well
that's an excellent question so
um my thought process behind the bill is
to allow uh you know my town clerk in
Epping
um she has a stack of municipally
elected uh details that she can
distribute
um the representative of that board who
chooses they would like to they choose
to elect to purchase that detail and
have that vanity plate
um obviously understand some of the
Amendments that I will intend to make
and I do appreciate everybody bringing
that up but
um if Epping say cooperated with Fremont
and Raymond they would also have said
stack of details and a prawn showing
proof that they are part of that
Cooperative School District school
committee or budget committee they would
also you know it would just be
um you know you'd be just just like your
regular plates whether in the town
clerk's office
uh last follow-up Mr chair
um
thank you
um it would um you've mentioned a couple
of time elected officials
um I'm assuming it would also transfer
to anyone that was appointed
in essence yes sir it would
representative um if someone was if say
the board of Selectmen had a opening and
they appointed somebody
um by non-vote or even just planning
board for example because that probably
happens more often than not they are
appointed uh they are sworn in yeah they
are a municipal official
okay thank you very much for your
answers
thank you representative Hill
representative Sykes
yes thank you Mr chairman
um having a little bit of
symbol I think this is
a fine idea in order to you know to make
this for a small way that people are
giving of their time and energy
in municipal offices could be have a
little bit of something for themselves
my anxiety though comes from the whole
how do the stickers get purchased who
pays for that initially
how is the money being handled most of
the
most of the non-profit organizations to
have taken this completely out of the
hands that the financial piece
completely out of the hands of DMV or
the state
and I'm I don't know how this would all
work and so it gives me a lot of anxiety
I'm not sure I'm not sure if there is a
mechanism under current law
for
the state to take in money from the sale
of these stickers and then
once those stickers are paid for
anything remaining would go back to the
general fund I understand what you would
tend to do but I'm not I don't see how
that could how that happens in in law or
so I just I bring that to your attention
um
I I don't have a fix yet maybe you'll be
able to find one for us between now and
whenever we exec this bill
that would be my hope representative
Sykes thank you um I will definitely be
well um I guess so I
normally the the only other times we've
had a
semi-quasi state agency involved it
happened to be the the Veterans Affairs
folks and that was created by
legislation as part of the whole decal
plate program
so I'm not sure the DOT
would have an answer for you if you're
going to answer wouldn't you go to DMV
yeah I guess DMV would be also somebody
that I should reach out to as well okay
I'm just trying to help you along not
not trying to give you a hard time like
I said no I get it I
I it's an actual not a bad idea but I
there's some
some
technical details that we have to work
on
versus DMV
um see representative Pulaski
thank you this is a question of the
chair perhaps you or one of the other
members who've been around longer than
me could answer do you remember the
history of putting the section
b3a the firefighter decals in there
because that seems similar in terms of a
municipal local program for decals
um but I'm not sure how that ended up
here
well I vaguely remember it um I was here
for the difference and that's why I
brought the similarities up to this bill
this morning even because it's municipal
and it is an exception to
the whole chapter
even within it it spells out who issues
the decals what the decals look like you
happen to be for full-time and retired
so there was no issue with women could
be taking or should be taken away now I
don't know if that answers your question
but that was my point although and again
too I'm not opposed to this necessarily
and it just raises a lot of questions I
don't know if that helped you
representative
it does thank you I just wanted a little
more clarity on how that one exception
got in there um as I've always
understood the program to be a
non-profit program thank you
George
yes this would also might be a question
for the chair but
um
my recollection of the firefighter decal
piece was that it was a very specific
for them separate and distinct from
authorized organizations and would and
as the sponsor suggests he might want to
put it in a different place within the
irsas but I also recall that there was
no fiscal
involvement of the state in that program
or in any town or city that the fire
department's
would find the money to run their own
stickers not wouldn't necessarily be
anything that the state did
is that not correct
thank you
which was why I was also surprised when
the UNH was having the town clerks issue
those I I thought that surprising as
well
any other questions let me scroll
seeing none
um we go through all this year the only
person I have signed up to testify
and Alaska members of the public if they
want to chime in quickly either via
telephone
or online if you could just contribute
you got it yeah over
the fish
that's to speak to this yeah
so
yes I can good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee can you hear me
again
great
um as outlined by a number of
um by a number of folks already we too
found a handful of technical defects
that we thought were a bit concerning
um
first and foremost
um you know being the intent other than
firefighters being
um
section 501
tax exempt was our first
we also in section 261 B3 in the in the
beginning this is also the intent shall
not be named for associated with
political issue or a person who seeks
holds or has held a public office
um that was a bit concerning as well and
then we also with lack of definition for
what a municipal officer is
um and there being a lack of
um display here to show proof of office
and how one would do that
in the event that somebody no longer
holds a public office who is responsible
to take that play to that decal back
if there's an Enforcement issue
with somebody refusing to give up that
plate who does that responsibility fall
to
and those with a handful of technical
defects again that we'd heard but I did
want to add to the end
what happens when somebody refuses to
give up that
decal and they're no longer
associated with the municipality
and with that I'll be willing to take
any questions you may have well thank
you I have one question I got your name
I tried to stop you to get who you might
represent but might have been a delay in
the uh in the zoom uh what do you
represent
my name is Jeff oberdeck and I represent
the division of motor vehicles uh
specifically the registration Bureau
you actually asked the same question
several times the same questions
is there anybody else that signed up for
the representative
okay
well I haven't seen anybody else chime
in uh on that last call so
representative thank you very much again
I'm not trying to beat anybody up just
looking at the bill and the questions it
raises so
right
thank you Mr chairman
how's that being said nobody else no I
didn't I didn't blow that one out too
bad yeah that was good so I have no
other figures how close the house
billboard
[Music]
foreign
okay
dokie
[Music]
taking care of that okay
um
public hearing on Hospital 423 and
that's establishing the commission the
commission to study the implementation
of enhanced automation of Tropic lights
uh representative to erosion
thank you and good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the esteem Transportation
committee
for the record my name is representative
Peter torosian I represent Rockingham
County District 14. the towns of
Atkinson and Plaistow
I'm here to present to you house bill
423 which establishes a commission to
study the implementation of enhanced
automation of traffic lights
I'll give you a little bit of background
on this bill
um with the attendance
I brought this bill for in a large term
last year as a matter of fact and the
reason I made it a commission the reason
it's back as a commission is because
there's a lot to do getting this going
um it's going to ultimately take some
money to uh to go to Spotlight
technology and I felt it was a good idea
to start with a commission to get it off
the ground
and um this this bill passed both the
House and Senate like she ain't got
bogged down with some of the bus bills
and the uh you know
the fact that a bunch of bills just
didn't get uh
through the process completely after uh
the covet constructs so so I'm back at
it again
um I think it's a good idea in the state
I don't know uh I bet mostly at one
point or another have sat at a traffic
light
in the state
um while you're waiting for the light to
turn and there's nobody coming on the
sidewinds so you know it's an
inefficient system we have right now
having said that we're better than many
states we have
kind of a phase one of the spotlight
technology in that we have
um
sensors on many of our
intersections that
at least when you if you're on a side
road when you when you pull up to the
sensor the light will eventually turn
how emotions works though is it's it's
used they use historical data of what
the traffic is in that area so there's
times you'll sit there for a while while
there's nobody coming so what spot like
technology does
um is it um
it uses technology to
get rid of some of that delay for
example
um if you have in combination with the
sensor and the
um
the jab on the road and then an eye up
above you will see when traffic's coming
so I know personally several times I've
sat on a side road watched the uh
you know the lights red nobody's coming
the other way
by the time this the sensor activates
and it turns it green to me now there's
traffic on the on the main road that
definitely
so with a with an eye you can he can
take he can
that would be kind of phase one of
enhancing our lights it would allow
individual lights to be more efficient
in a lot of traffic to Florida more uh
you know sufficient way
phase two would be then having
the light stock to each other and when
that happens and you can
have efficiencies uh much greater for us
now obviously and what I'm talking about
here is only the traffic lights that are
owned by the state of New Hampshire so
most towns well most small towns are
probably State like but in in cities
they're they're city of light so it
won't affect those
but in places that have used this
technology and gotten up to speed uh
State of Rhode Island uses it in places
as many cities that use it you can see
travel times uh increased by as much as
25 percent
delays
waiting in intersections and drop as
much as 40 30 to 40 percent less stops
at traffic lights which is quite safe
with drivers and with reduced
we run tires or breaks and so forth and
for people that maybe don't care about
sitting there the other advantages up to
a 20 reduction in their vehicle
emissions so it seems like a win-win
situation in my mind and so I hope you
consider um
supporting this bill and uh passing it
I think that's pretty much everything I
wanted to say about it other than I did
send
earlier today to the chairman to
disseminate a link for a company that
I've talked to would be glad to just
find the information the committee would
like some other companies out there
company called rapid flow that has
implemented this technology in many
places and so
um with that I'll open it up if any
committee members have a question
thank you representative any questions
no it's simply a sensitive to you could
almost even call it a motion sensor to
determine traffic's coming right now you
have the sensor on the road that the
vehicle pulls up to the sensor and
nobody there eventually changes it
doesn't know whether it's traffic coming
thank you Mr chairman
um representative torosion on
line 17 of your bill talks about the
commission shell study the
implementation of enhanced automation of
traffic lights and I just wondered if
you had a little more detail about what
enhanced automation meant
go under under Park line 17 the
foreign
so on line 17 it's it's the owner line
that talks about the charge of the
commission and it says it shall study
the implementation of enhanced
automation of traffic lights and I
wondered if we had
if representative torosion had more
detail about what is meant by enhanced
automation
well it's basically what I was referring
to study the uh what I just said the
efficiencies that could be gained in the
can I have a follow-up Mr chairman
yeah he still he was still speaking
maybe you can't hear him no I can't no
before that microphone a little closer
perhaps
representative can you hear me any
better now yes
I guess I didn't have the mic close
enough I apologize so what I was saying
was on the line 17 the commission shall
studied the implementation of enhanced
automation of traffic lights and what
several pieces to get this implemented
first of all you want to study and see
where it would be the fact of and then
perhaps busier intersections where you
have potential of getting more you know
efficiencies for the less ones
who communicate with each other it
actually uses intelligence some of the
Sonata systems who have gain the
efficiencies we're looking for
um so the basically Commission in a
nutshell would be
the ground in in and come up best way to
implement it in the state ultimately we
may have to go back and have a bill to
enact that but it's it's kind of phase
one of trying to get the
thing off the ground
thank you could I have a follow-up Mr
chairman
yeah
boy
um sorry but a lot of
I presume you gave me permission so I'll
continue sorry um
George representative Sykes I'm as close
to this microphone as I dare get am I
coming in any better now yeah that's
better I presume you gave me permission
yes you did you did thank you
representative torosion so as I
understand what you've the bill presents
it's more about the implementation of
um
existing systems that might apply to
traffic signals
and my question is had you given any
thought about also studying
what other systems may be coming down
the road as well so as an example
it's one thing to talk about existing
systems that we have now but in the not
too near
future
um
traffic lights traffic signals will be
able to talk to automated Vehicles I'm
not talking about cars that drive
themselves but rather that cars have
systems that allow them to talk to the
signals as well as the signals to talk
back to the cars and I know dot is doing
a lot of work on that but I I wonder if
that should be included in the scope
of your bill
um yeah I would agree with that
certainly
um
uh yeah go ahead it's very poor but I
think I've got you better now
yeah
so ultimately sure the idea is to get
this off the ground you know you gotta
for all before your walk so to speak so
local
okay
and I think you may not be able to hear
me
yeah I'm not sure that I'm the only one
who can't
um
it's it's a bit of a problem I I'll take
it from you that you that maybe you
wouldn't be
um
opposed to an amendment that included
additional language to look at
technology not just an implementation
policy
I I would agree with that I would
certainly be agree with that and
ultimately that is part of what we're
okay
representative
uh again I don't think it's just me but
uh it is better right this second
I've got it right I don't know if you
can you probably can't have same people
I've got it right here anyway four
inches from my mouth so anyway I hope I
answered that question yeah anyway yeah
I think you did these people who haven't
happened having a hard time hearing this
yeah I understand but thanks and I kind
of agree with them rather than making
the charge too big maybe more detail
it's a simple Amendment would be helpful
sure I wouldn't be opposed to that
any other questions from the committee
yep it was up ataro thank you Mr chair
um and uh thank you representative uh
ferocian
um
uh line 28
to me this sort of thing seems complex
and has a lot of inherent variables like
you listed out four or five variables
already about which lights do which
lights don't the technology itself Etc
in in this in this bill it says to
sunset on November 1st 2021. you think
that is enough time should the committee
be formed to review all this
um it's not a lot of time the the chair
may explain to you further why those
dates out the way they are
typically for these they've got a report
for the next session
and so that's why you see section one
take effect and then it then then the
sun sets itself so if they didn't get
all their work done then the best way
would be to do another study commission
and start over all right in other words
we commission's not going to go on for
years and years and years
seeing as how we're only here for two
so basically at the report something by
that time right I see okay if it's
insufficient then then the next step
would be to reintroduce through another
commission I see okay you know if I may
Mr chair if enough work
is completed it may lead to introduction
of a further legislation next year if
unlikely would be that quick but to get
the ball rolling another step closely
in getting lights installed because the
commission's not going to have the
authority to do that per se
but it's it's it's the getting it off
the ground getting the discussion going
I see okay the end goal of a committee
study committee or a commission
is to have enough recommendations that
there is something that the guy can
actually file a bill with so that's the
goal I see Joe representative Sykes with
his hand back up
question
I know the Senate
Senate typically
um
I don't know how I quite want to say
this they often have trouble accepting
bills for commissions and uh in line
seven I'm sorry line eight there's three
members of the Senate I have never seen
three members of the Senate appointed to
a commission we're usually lucky to get
one I I wonder if you if you feel that
this might be a problem
well I I'll take that one if you don't
mind that you are absolutely right
representative
we send them
the committee or commission with two
they usually if they even like the
context they'll amend it and make it one
and then that one won't show up either
so
um leave it up to the sponsor and if he
would like to make a possible change to
that but uh point taken
thank you yeah I'd be fine with that I
was trying to keep it balanced uh trying
to keep you know
make it so that there'd be more interest
in supporting it as as opposed to less
and sometimes you get into turf wars
where you know you guys have three
members we only have one but Point well
taken I'm certainly uh agreeable to
amend that
foreign
okay
uh Mr Lambert from the Department of
Transportation
good morning or good afternoon can you
uh can you all hear me
hear you all right thank you
um Mr chairman uh thank you for inviting
me or to speak and thank you members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Bill Lambert I'm the state traffic
engineer for the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation
uh and I guess I'd start by asking if
you were able to get the uh the written
testimony that I submitted
I submitted a letter kind of providing
some background into traffic signal
development and I'm seeing a couple head
nods
so I won't read that I'll just kind of
summarize
um for the purpose of this hearing so
the Department of Transportation uh
supports any effort to improve Mobility
on on state highways and all highways so
we'd certainly look forward to working
with the commission uh on that in that
regard
um but I did want you to give be aware
of kind of the history of traffic
signals in the in the state
um first traffic signal I think the
first traffic signal in the state was
installed in 1949 I want to say that was
in Manchester
I don't know precisely where that was
but the first state traffic signal
started popping up in the 1950s more in
the 60s
mostly in kind of the rural State
Highway to State Highway intersection
um time traffic signals and
signalization was more common in the
urban areas Manchester Nashua
um Salem places like that
um and less common on the state highways
but over the years
um as some of the commercial corridors
started expanding and you'd start string
several
um traffic signals together the um
coordinated system started to come in
probably in the 1980s where particularly
places like 101a and Nashua Amherst
Milford where you would have several
traffic signals kind of consecutively
within a half mile of each other uh so
you would start stringing those together
with interconnected cables uh and you
would have timing plans that would time
a progression so that once you're in the
the progression or on the corridor you
would theoretically be able to
um catch green light after green light
that works best when there's full
traffic it doesn't work so well when
there's not a lot of traffic because
then you get the situation that
representative torosion spoke about
where somebody might be sitting at a
side road looking at no traffic coming
along not wondering why they have to
wait so long uh when what they're really
doing is waiting for that progression uh
to start at one end and continue all the
way through
um
traffic signals is representative to
Trojan said that there's sensors and
traffic signals all of the State traffic
signals so 450 traffic signals or so
do have what we call actuation or
they're fully actuated which means that
every movement
um is detected so every lane every every
turning lane would be detected either by
inductive Loops in the pavement or by
cameras more recently
um that are above the the intersection
that would be either a camera for each
direction or one camera that would look
at all approaches
so those detection devices will tell the
controller that somebody's waiting for
the for a phase and typically a traffic
signal will rest green on the main
Direction so the main Highway would be
green if there's no traffic on the road
but if somebody's turning left off that
road or they're crossing the road they
would be
um detected and then the controller
would call that phase in the phase
sequence goes into similar cycle
um so that's pretty much all of our
signals but one thing to note that
especially with the inductive Loops that
are in the pavement uh if we have a
failed inductive Loop that happens this
time of year we're probably not going to
fix that until sometime in the summer uh
just because we can't be cutting into
pavement and and doing that kind of work
in the winter time
um we would probably do a lot of those
over the winter and in those cases
traffic signals would be set on what we
call recall so they would they would
tend to run the same cycle every time
where the traffic was coming or not so
that's that's kind of the default case
if there's faulty
um detection that we can't restore and
one of the advantages of cameras other
than that the more expensive is that we
can fix detection when it fails
um
because we can do that kind of work in
the winter time
so I I did want to mention that in 2009
we solicited a Federal Highway to come
in and do a traffic signal assessment or
audit of our of our process and our
resources they give us a plan in 2009
that
identified some of the I guess lower
hanging fruit that opportunities for
improvement they did mention that in the
10-year plan there's not an active
traffic signal operations and
maintenance item so we don't have a
program Capital project for something
like that and I've said over the years
that with 400 traffic 50 traffic signals
and we typically will
estimate that a signal is good for 25 to
30 years that if you do the number we
should be updating or replacing eight to
ten traffic signals a year and we don't
come anywhere near that
so that was one thing that they noticed
they noticed that we had a good
foundation and a commitment dedication
to staff but Staffing was inadequate
we've got the same number of technicians
maintaining 450 signals now that we had
in the 70s and 80s maintaining less than
half of that so they definitely noted
that and one of the challenges for the
D.O.T is that our traffic signals can
often be spread by hours
um from one place to the other so the
tax technicians working on a traffic
signal in Claremont might be called to
fix one in Gorham and that's not a short
ride
um so when they look at numbers of
traffic signals per technician in an
urban environment it's a little
different than it would be for us
they determined that the dot was not
well positioned to proactively manage
signals due to the functional
Communications limitations so
essentially what they're saying which
kind of gets into this bill is that we
were not necessarily using the available
technology to communicate with from our
headquarters to the traffic signals so a
lot of times our traffic signal
technicians are getting complaints about
a call that a Signal's not not cycling
properly or the Signal's not functioning
we get kind of vague complaints about
what's wrong with the signals and we're
not able to triage those calls by
connecting to the controller remotely to
make sure that everything's working all
right we typically have to send a
technician out to the to the site and
and open the cabinet door to do that
and then they also noted the primary
performance measure was our response to
Citizen complaints
so we didn't have any proactive
performance measures that we had
reactive measures
um so that that was some of the things
that they identified out of that study
um since that time
we reorganized our traffic signal
maintenance operation section so that we
were taking more of a we're pending the
focus Less on Strictly the maintenance
and response and try to be more
proactive and look at systems management
and operation
uh so we've actually put a fairly senior
engineering position on top of our
signal group
we've developed a reliable inventory so
that we know what we have not just the
number of signals but what's in the
cabinet
um we're working on developing
appropriate and measurable performance
measures
uh and looking for opportunities to use
emerging traffic signal technology
Technologies particularly those related
to detection and Signal efficiency
signal system efficiency
one of the things that that these
signals don't do and a lot of people
think that
some timing changes will make things
work better
um but it gets to a point when we have
saturated traffic conditions and I know
representative Sykes is probably
familiar with the exit 18 Corridor in
Lebanon
um we've got fairly High volumes of
traffic coming from three different
directions at the same time in the
morning
you there's not a lot that adaptive or
signal technology can do uh with those
things because
um signals by definition of creating
delay and it's there's only so much they
um so a couple more points I wanted to
make that we do have adaptive signal
control in a couple of areas and that
exit 18 area in Lebanon is one of those
areas so adaptive signal control is
essentially a term that means
you add additional
um
detection at a signal so you can detect
advance of the intersections and then
you can the the Adaptive system will
adjust the timing and phasing
values in real time and not a
coordinated system like we've did
initially would be where we would do
some traffic counts and project an
average condition and we would design
timings for that average condition
um but if there was something happened
that was different from that average the
signals wouldn't change to adapt to that
adapter signals can use real-time
traffic volumes and and adjust the
phasing and timing to represent those
real-time changes to traffic
so in that letter I did describe what um
the difference between the actuated
signal is a coordinated system and
adaptive signals
um I know that was a three-page
testimony and I've probably gone on
longer than I should in the in this
verbal testimony uh signals can be
pretty complicated
um I know in a lot of cases where we've
optimized traffic signal timing and
phasing through a corridor
our our technicians get a lot of
complaints because what we've done when
we try to optimize the throughput along
a corridor is we've penalized some of
the intersecting side roads
um I know I've been in some urban areas
and other other states where as a marked
difference in how much time people are
willing to wait to enter a corridor or
to make a lot left turn off Corridor uh
I think in a lot of ways we've spoiled
traffic to to expect if they've come up
to a light and they don't see anybody
moving they're going to get a green
light right away
um oftentimes if it's that one car that
that turns that phase you're going to
get a minimum time for that phase so
you're kind of wasting a phase for one
vehicle at a time we'd like to be able
to stack more Vehicles than that but
people aren't always patient enough to
wait for more cars to come behind them
um so with that
um again signals can be pretty
complicated I don't know if I can answer
all the questions but I'd be happy to
thank you Mr Lambert uh any questions
representative Hill
thank you Mr chair and uh and thank you
Mr Lambert for your testimony um
you and I have had this conversation
um not too long ago about uh the route 3
uh
intersection at exit 20
um up in Tilton
and you explained it uh clearly to me
then
um that anytime you get into these
intersection
um
dilemmas there's always a trade-off
there's either uh
um talking about the side roads you're
you're disadvantaging those side roads
in order to keep the traffic flowing I
appreciated
um your testimony again today and I'm
wondering
is it your belief that this legislation
um is somehow misguided or should not be
taken is that is that what I'm hearing
yeah I I didn't want I thank you for the
question representative Hill uh I didn't
want it to come off as being
uh we certainly support anything that
can improve mobility and there's
certainly room for improvement in our
traffic signal operations
um I think the commission uh would be
valuable if for nothing else than to
give
uh I think the folks in the committee uh
in the legislature an idea of what we
have done and what things we'd like to
do
um and what that might cost moving
forward so I think it would be a good
idea a good way
uh first of all I think we could share
the assessment that we had done in 2009
so you could see 10 years ago what we
were looking to do
um as a place to start and then and move
on from there it is a lot of work uh I
agree with the comment that to that the
August 2021 might be pretty short but I
think we could probably Identify some of
great thank you very much
representative Gorski
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
Mr Lambert for your testimony
um in regards to this commission if they
come up with a report
and make some recommendations and I
understand it really depends
on the technology on that on what
they're Rec what what they're
recommending
can you give a sub like a ballpark on
like how long it would take to implement
um
it's it's hard to say without knowing
what the recommendations are but I'll
use that assessment and again thank you
for the question
I'll use the assessment that we had done
in 2009
one of the things that they pointed out
is that we we may not have been taking
advantage of all the alternative funding
and Manpower resources that were
available so they were recommending that
we look into
um
Mutual uh funding with some of the
municipalities and places where where
our coordinated systems overlap
um so we were able to do that kind of
thing
um
fairly quickly we identified certainly
the the obvious choices like the
Manchester Nashua
um and some of the places where the
local interest in coordinating signals
so a state interchange were pretty high
but we also use that as a reason for
starting our annual Workshop where we
did
we hosted a workshop where it was
essentially allowing the municipalities
and the state DOT traffic signal folks
to share some best practices
and that was one of the things we got
out of that assessment so some of those
things are pretty easy to implement
because there's not a lot of cost to
them
uh it's when you start looking at
um maybe adding adaptive signals where
that's going to mean putting more
advanced detection could be as much as a
hundred uh or several hundred thousand
depending on how complicated the
corridor is
that would end up having to be in a
budget process and maybe even um some
dedicated funding through the capital
okay thank you Mr Lambert
good thing
I don't see any other questions from the
committee
well there are one more representative
thank you Mr chair
um and thank you Mr Lambert
um this assessment from 2009 was that
another study commission or was that an
that was in thank you for the question
that was an internal assessment that we
requested through Federal Highway their
Resource Center had an opportunity for
us to have a I guess an independent
auditor assessment of our program and it
came at a time when we
um
from the 1980s to the 1970s I think
until the late 90s even into the 2000s
we had two different people that were
responsible for our traffic signal
operation uh with a lot of experience in
in that 2007-8 time period uh the second
of those people retired so that we were
we were kind of starting from scratch
and looking for kind of a baseline of
where we are and where we want to be so
we had we had reached out to Federal
Highway they had the resource available
uh and they did a fairly comprehensive
assessment uh with some of their subject
matter experts and I can make that
good thank you
no other questions thank you very much
Mr Lambert
thank you have a nice day good to see
okay
um that's all I have for
uh
they have signed up
um
any last-minute arrivals for anybody
else that would like wish to speak on
there is another one sorry
uh that looks good let me see if I can
do this Alex controvers
yes sir thank you can you hear me
you can good afternoon
good afternoon uh thank you for the
opportunity to provide feedback on House
Bill 423
I'm here today representing the American
Council of engineering companies of New
Hampshire
we're an association of about 75
engineering and related firms
they employ over 1500 New Hampshire
residents and they're engaged in a wide
range of public and private engineering
works
Professional Engineers from New
Hampshire consulting firms are often
hired by both state and local
governments to perform traffic
Engineering Services
we are speaking today to request an
amendment to the legislation
the bill as introduced does not mandate
a civil or traffic engineer be a part of
the study
our simple request is to add a
professional engineer from our
association to the commission we feel
it's important that the bill be clear
that a private sector engineer who very
often is performing these Services under
contract by state and local government
be a part of the study
in addition
we would ask that you consider adding a
representative from the New Hampshire
Public Works Association or the New
Hampshire Municipal Association as you
know much of the traffic engineering and
other relevant issues are discussed and
performed at the city and town level
and we feel that their perspective on
this issue would be valuable to the
commission's mission
so that's all I have Mr chairman I
appreciate your consideration and if I
can answer any questions I'd be happy to
do so
[Music]
in terms of the blue sheets we have uh
two other people that signed up and
member of the public also supports this
kind of with that we're going to close
the public hearing on household 423
to give our clerk a couple of minutes to
um
can you hear me yeah now I can thank you
uh Mr chairman can you get me get to the
committee members that the name of the
gentleman who just last testify in the
name of his Professional Organization
because he I think he made some points
that we may want to follow up on
yep I can give it to you right now if
you like it
uh his name is Alex
[Music]
yeah I got Alex but not the rest of it
all right we're having now we're going
to uh we're having a farm issues it
sounds like
yeah
but maybe you can give it to or Brad can
send a note to us or something like that
okay yes I can say that over to you
representative sakes if that's okay
we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 424 an act establishing a
committee to study ways to reduce
texting while driving
representative
welcome again
I'm still here
thank you again Mr chair and members of
the transportation committee
uh once again for the record my name is
Peter Trojan I represent the Rockingham
County district 14 towns of Atkinson and
Plaistow
I'm here on this one again to
um ask for your support on House Bill
establishment a commission to study ways
to reduce texting while driving
this is another bill that was passed by
both bodies last year and got
kind of shoveled on the table because
all of what's going on
I think it's still needed nothing's
changed since then so I'm back again
asking you to uh
yeah
hopefully
again I'll tell you the reason why this
is a commission instead of
bill
or instead of a you know something that
creates either fines or fees or taking
somebody's license away because we've
had a bunch of those over the years
and they don't seem to work
I don't know about any of you at all but
when I drove up today this morning to go
to my committee for hearings
I lost count on the number of people I
saw texting on the highway and for that
matter the back roads it's a problem
it's a safety issue and as you may have
gathered from my last testimony I
believe in
creating efficiencies in our traffic
flow where we can and this is another
place in addition to the safety issues
you have
except before a light behind somebody
that was at the beginning of the line
that had to finish that text before they
uh they could move on so it's an
inconvenience it's also
um for its efficiency and I would argue
with also adds to more missions you know
vehicle emissions than there may be
otherwise
and again the reason why it's a
commission is
quite simply this bill attempts to bring
the interested parties
to the table to solve the ongoing
problem I don't think you can do it with
enforcement because we've done that and
it didn't seem to make it any better
maybe the loss
bill that made it illegal legal in New
Hampshire in the beginning maybe helped
a little bit but the numbers have seem
to come back up and I heard from law
enforcement supporting that
fact
so I believe we this is another place we
need to use the technology to solve the
problem
there are devices that commercial
Trucking uses there's one called a
vector that
it just simply disables your mobile
device while the vehicle's in motion
I don't know that that would work
completely for a passenger vehicle
because it may and it may disable
everybody's device and passengers that
I'm driving certainly uh shouldn't be
impacted um and would be probably upset
about it so this bill
attempts to get a commission together
members of law enforcement
I was the Senate members of the uh
industry
both technology and automobile to come
up with a solution I I believe if we put
our heads together we can we can solve
the problem at least make it more
manageable
so
that is the reason for the
for the bill I hope you support it and
with that I'll take any questions the
thank you representative Rosen you did
say this one did pass last year I forget
yeah this one did as well they both did
well I've got both notes off the one
before also yes okay thank you uh any
questions from the committee
representative Aaron
thank you uh Mr chair
so I am curious to know why this would
have to be some sort of statutory
Commission
wouldn't wouldn't it be better for say
the Department of Public Safety to have
some kind of Symposium or have you know
a conference of some sort to bring
parties together to discuss
ways in which
uh this problem could be a you know
tackle maybe they can do a public
education
uh you know advertising campaign or
something like that I don't see that
this is
legislative kind of thing to do
okay I'll be glad to answer that
kind of question this is more of a
statement representative and I'll answer
it this way
um I would certainly welcome that but
the reality is uh since texting has
become a problem
it hasn't happened and so I think
well I just plagiar certainly has the
responsibility to look at safety issues
I think this you know it would be
beneficial to solve the problem in my
opinion that's why I'm before you today
um could it be done another way it
perhaps it could
um
sometimes it takes something more
organized to to get the
get the ball rolling and so uh you know
if you could come into a way to make
that happen without a commission that
would be great
um I think it's one of those you know uh
elephants in the room people don't like
to talk about the problem the texture
presents because everybody likes to
everybody likes their devices and they
like in one hand they acknowledge it's a
safety issue they acknowledge it's an
inconvenience when you're stuck behind
somebody you can see it when you're on
the road in somebody's going really slow
then they speed up when they're done
texting and then they slow down again so
you know
I'm open to any and every way to solve
the problem I I I said in the onset I
don't think the the uh we've had again
bills to increase the fines and after
three strikes and you're out you lose
your license kind of thing
this is an addictive behavior as far as
I can tell and so you have to find a way
through technology to solve the problem
that's that's why I'm here with this
mission
okay
um
so you know other questions from the
committee do we I do have another person
signed up to speak thank you
representative
um
[Music]
Dan Goodman from AAA
I am can you hear me okay
thank you very much chairman Walsh
um and thank you members of the
committee for giving me a few minutes
um today uh for the record my name is
Dan Goodman and I am the manager of
public affairs for AAA Northern England
and for those who don't know AAA is an
auto club membership organization of
over 100 million members in Maine New
Hampshire and Vermont and we actively
advocate for public policy that makes
New Hampshire a safer place to live work
and raise our families
um I'm here in support of this bill
um I sent my written testimony last
night so I'll be extremely brief I just
wanted to touch on a few points
this is an extremely timely bill
um as traffic deaths in New Hampshire
have increased over the last over the
last year over throughout the pandemic
despite fewer drivers on the road law
enforcement is saying distracted driving
is playing an increasing factor in a lot
of these deaths
um and we have done just a ton a ton of
research on this topic
and over the last eight to ten years and
to quickly speak on all that research
probably a dozen studies
you know any cell phone use behind the
wheel is extremely dangerous and
actually quadruple is your crash risks
and texting as this bill wants to talk
about increase your crash risk 23 23
times worse than driving while not
distracted and we also produce an annual
survey across the country and
consistently about 80 to 85 percent of
drivers say distraction is just a
serious serious issue that we need to
talk about
um and so really just to conclude is
representative torosion said I think
it's really important that we need to
look at every opportunity to reduce
distracted driving and to make New
Hampshire roads a safer to make as safe
as possible and I hope you'll support
this bill and um that's that's it and
thank you and I'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you Mr chair uh thank you Mr
Goodman um
my my question is
um
about kind of like the status quo and
and what might be hope to be achieved by
this you mentioned that there are
numerous other studies and research done
into this can you cite any other
advancements or anything any other
examples that other states or anybody
else has done to I don't know clamp down
on this more or whatever
thank you representative for that
question
um I think for a more thoughtful answer
um if you wouldn't mind I'd be happy to
kind of
dive into that and kind of come up with
what other states are doing and I think
what representative torosion talked
about you know a lot of states are doing
you know increased fines
um there's a lot of
public service announcements PSAs New
Hampshire does a great great job their
office of Highway Safety on producing
PSAs and educational components
um there's a there's annual conferences
and there's
um you know New Hampshire has the
traffic safety commission that I sit on
a governor appointed Traffic Safety
commission and we regularly meet about
distracted driving and figuring out it's
a collaborative private public
partnership throughout throughout the
state trying to figure out ways that we
can tackle distracted driving among the
other issues
um so there are a lot of different ways
to go about this I think a commission is
a great idea to bring more people
together
um but I think long and short of it is
I'm not really familiar
of some very successful ways to reduce
distracting driving off top of my head
from other states but I'd be happy to
look into it
great thank you
representative polarski
thank you very much
thank you for taking my question Mr
Goodman I'm looking at the membership of
the commission and other than five
legislators
we have a designee from the Department
of Transportation a designee of the
Department of Safety and then a
representative that of the
Telecommunications industry would you
like to see another
um member perhaps from an organization
similar to yours or can you recommend
someone else who is maybe
um
more fluent in the the data the studies
I just I'm just wondering if the
membership is is
a little Limited
uh thank you representative for that
question uh I I you know I I think AAA
would be happy to participate uh in this
sort of uh commission
um we're regularly just doing uh
probably as much research as anyone on
this topic so I'd be happy to to share
the most recent data that's coming out
most of our data we team at the
University of Utah
um for a lot of This research so I'd be
happy to and um I don't have the bill in
front of me I should
um and I don't know if uh the
representative has included the auto
dealers I think having having them on
that would be
um would be beneficial I'm just thinking
of other private organizations that are
involved
I think having more people around the
table is always a good
so
thank you for your feedback on that
thanks
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking my question I
um
a fellow I am friendly with that is much
smarter than I once suggested
um
an action that could take place
um rather quickly that would uh
um affect texting and driving and I'm
wondering if um if you might have an
opinion on that from the AAA standpoint
or whether you know if this idea has
been tried anywhere
um the idea was that if uh through legal
action if if you could say the insurance
companies aren't required to um to pay
for a claim if if the insurance company
could prove that you were doing
something like texting and driving at
the time that the accident occurred
um has that been ever tried anywhere
that you know of
um within your AAA Network and by the
way I am a in full disclosure AAA
convert thank you
well representative thank you for the
question and thank you for being a
member
I I don't to be honest with you I don't
know the answer that but I'd be happy to
kind of um
dig through some of the the insurance
infra data that's out there and and uh
as well as the first question I was
asked kind of get a gather a little bit
more information for you and get back to
you if that would work but I apologize I
don't I can't really comment on that
any other questions from the committee
man thank you very much Mr Goodman
okay um do we have any anybody added on
representative
okay uh two other people that have
signed up in support of this Bill Morrow
Weston uh representing a T and T and our
friend Eric Rathbun a member of the
public representing himself also in
support
with that I'm going to close the public
wow
bingo
okay
we openly with Publishers on House Bill
260 FM
and that's relative to another place for
Motor Vehicles
we're representative Providence
I have to do thank you Mr chairman I'm
Andrew Prout representing Hillsborough
County District 37 the towns of Hudson
and Pelham
this bill will eliminate the requirement
for a passenger vehicle to display a
front license plate
the mounting of a front license plate
can have significant effect on the value
of certain vehicles
this is especially true with collectible
cars higher end sports cars and imported
vehicles that may not have been designed
for North American shaped license plate
additionally car manufacturers have been
seeking to optimize the aerodynamic
profile of their vehicles to maximize
fuel efficiency
but the front plate Mount on vehicles is
optional equipment and not included in
EPA testing there's no incentive to
optimize it as it doesn't affect the
vehicles with only rear license plates
are already on the roads
20 States and 9 out of 13 Canadian
provinces and territories do not require
front license plates
seven additional states have exemptions
for certain vehicle types or categories
our neighbor Vermont effectively
repealed the requirement to have a
unique front license plate that is
useful for identification first
temporarily in 2012 this temporary
measure was made permanent in 2016.
Ohio repealed its front plate
requirement on passenger vehicles
effective in 2019.
the fiscal note on this bill assumes the
department would continue manufacturing
two plates in every set and only require
the vehicle owner to pay for one to
forecast the fiscal loss to the state as
a result of this bill
I'm surprised that the pool of
non-commercial vehicles in the state
wouldn't be large enough to justify the
production and maintenance of a separate
set of one plate stock
according to news reports Ohio expected
to save 1.4 million dollars per year by
making fewer plates following its repeal
even though it lowered its registration
costs when implementing the change
thank you I also submitted to the
committee written testimony with this
information and some more details which
hopefully you all received and thank you
for your time and consideration I'll be
happy to answer any questions you may
have
any questions from the committee
foreign
thank you
the John Drury uh from the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police is here
[Music]
I'm on the line chairman can you hear me
okay
now good afternoon
good afternoon uh thank you chairman
Walsh and members of the committee my
name is John Drury I'm the police chief
in Farmington New Hampshire
um I've just started my 22 second year
in law enforcement I'm also a member of
the Stratford County Accident
reconstruction team and have been for
about 15 years I'm here to testify in
opposition to HB 260fn relative to
number plates for Motor Vehicles on
behalf of myself and the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police I
submitted written testimony so I don't
want to bore you uh in rereading that to
you
um I submitted it yesterday so I hope
um over the years a front license plate
has uh made my job much easier
um I've seen them imprinted into the
side of houses into the sides and the
rears of other vehicles
um in Hit and Run situations
um I actually personally witnessed one
where a car about 15 miles an hour uh
hit the rear of a an old Crown Vic
um that happened to have my old chief of
police in it and it was only about a 10
or a 15 mile an hour crash and that
license plate imprinted perfectly on the
rear of that old Crown Vic and that
person stayed behind obviously they
weren't going to go too far with several
officers standing around directing
traffic around uh one of our sidewalk
plows had fallen off the sidewalk and
tipped over on that particular day and
but it was a perfect example of of just
uh you know how these license plates do
hold up in a Collision they are very
reflective and they stand out really
well in the night time I've always been
able to see them well
and if you can imagine I've got three
roads that run through my town Route 11
Route 75 Route 153 and we're also near
the Spalding Turnpike we get a lot of
bolos from the city of Rochester and
Dover and we're always seeing to at
least once or twice a day be looking out
for a vehicle
um that another city or another
Community has asked us to look out for
and those roads are anywhere from 40 to
50 to 55 miles an hour and having a
front license plate just makes my life
so much easier when I'm trying to look
at a vehicle that's passing me at uh 75
or 80 feet per second
and being able to to see it I mean we
are obviously also looking for the color
of the car and things like that but
um you know we'd have to spin around to
look for a particular vehicle and try
and get behind it and probably pull over
a few people
accidentally that we're uh we were
looking for a similar car but uh what it
was right up until the last moment uh
perhaps even when the officer would have
hit the blue lights pull somebody over
to realize that it's not the right plate
we're looking for
um those are just a few of the things
that I can see
um you know I'm a car guy I I
like a nice clean front end of my car
um but uh the uh the safety
um and being able to identify it through
that front plate has served me well my
whole career
um in aerodynamics I spoke to a
mechanical engineer who also works on
the accident reconstruction team and you
have to remember that that front license
plate is being followed by two thousand
pounds or more of vehicle behind it the
engine and the
radiator and all of that uh that's going
over and around and underneath the car
so I think aerodynamically the front
license plate being six inches wide and
12 inches all right so I'm sorry 12
inches wide and six inches tall isn't
going to affect gas mileage much we're
going to lose more gas mileage than
people that have un under inflated tires
uh than we do by having someone with a
front plate on their car
um in closing I oppose the bill
um because of the safety of the public
outweighs my car guy vanity
um and I would respectfully ask that you
find the bill in expedient to legislate
having two plates just makes it so much
easier to locate a stolen motor vehicle
for us it allows for Witnesses and
victims to have a better chance of
seeing plates of a suspicious vehicle
involved in crimes you know when a
person pulls into a convenience store to
rob it there's a chance that that uh
store will have surveillance equipment
that will pick up that car's license
plate for us and help us solve a crime
and it has done so in the past so I'm
more than happy to answer any questions
I don't want to bore you with the
testimony I already provided you with
and I greatly appreciate you allowing me
I see representative to ask you a
question
thank you thank you Chief jury for
taking my question
um in terms of the front license plate I
know that law enforcement or maybe a
little more experienced in how to look
and quickly you know identify a plate do
you think that when it comes to the
general public in terms of things such
as Amber Alerts
um or any one of those things we see on
the news or in the flashing dot signs do
you think that having a front plate
helps the public in being able to spot
those and that might actually make a
difference in in a situation of Crisis
perhaps with a missing child
I definitely do thank you for that
question I think by having the front
plate you're
perhaps not quite twice as likely to
find that person but I just think it
makes it much more much easier with cars
coming towards you
um Cars and Cars going away from you
I've always found it easier to read the
plate as the vehicle is approaching me
is the Plate's getting bigger the
vehicle's getting bigger instead of as
the vehicle passes me and it's getting
smaller and chasing away and especially
where now with our state having a seven
digit plate that's a lot of numbers to
get quickly in a short amount of time so
I really think it it does help and then
you know to touch on uh you know you
have people that transport bicycles on
the back of their cars you have people
that are working that may have a ladder
or a tailgate down bringing home plywood
from Home Depot or someplace and I think
just that front Place increases our odds
of getting a uh getting a good
identification on the car
thank you very much
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Chief Drury
um does the State of New Hampshire do
police departments here use automatic
license plate readers and if so
um wouldn't that negate some of the uh
concerns that might be had about
um identifying Vehicles going at a high
enforcement agency agencies to use
um the those uh it'll be quite a long
time before they end up in my department
um I don't even have mdts in my cars
because I think it's more important for
my officers
to have their eyes on the road and to
have their eyes on what they're looking
out the windows at
um I do think license plate readers are
coming
um and like I say they were authorized
with a lot of restrictions in them
um my understanding is and you may have
to correct me if I'm wrong I'm not a uh
it's something that I hadn't considered
from my agency so I'm not up to date on
them but I believe the data is only held
in the system for about three minutes
um and I think it it is a wonderful tool
um but I think that that uh technology
is still a long ways off for us
um and to add to it uh you know the
license plate Rita would only see I
would imagine what the human eye would
in a vehicle coming towards us
um I would assume they probably would
work as a vehicle going away from us as
well but
um with the price of a cruiser right now
being about thirty one thousand dollars
and then another ten thousand dollars to
minimally outfit it
um and I have six Cruisers from my town
alone
um I'm assuming that uh that information
and that technology is going to add a
significant amount on to onto my budget
as well that
um I'm not going to sell to my board of
thank you Mr chairman thank you Chief
Drury
my question was similar in that uh
automated readers are only good if they
can see the plate
so reducing the plates by half
would reduce the identification
possibilities by half I know Nashua uses
identification
processing and it's been very very
helpful
so I just wanted to
you asked you you answered the same
you're welcome
representative
uh yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I'm wondering
about other states
um I know that there's at least a few
that that have uh the one plate
requirement
um are there records are there
um studies that show they have
difficulty in the areas that you
mentioned are are the advantage of
having front plates
I can tell you that in front of me
um I was able to get a hold of some
information from
um as well as a couple of other states
uh the one information that I found came
oddly enough from the Vermont petroleum
Association
um and that I have not confirmed this
information it was provide provided to
um as part of their testimony to the
Vermont's house Transportation was that
motor vehicle used in 70 percent of all
serious crimes throughout the United
States according to a study by the
national associations of chiefs of
police
um so that was kind of the one of the
the big takebacks I had I understand
there are quite a few you know states
that that uh require
um only the real plate
um you know when I look at things and
and looking at our you know our toll
booths throughout the state those are
things that are going to have to be
adjusted
um to be able to capture only a real
play
um and uh that technology as well as
those cameras
um and if I have a hitch on my vehicle
with only one plate am I now obstructing
the um
you know that license plate
um as well as you know like a bicycle on
the back of a car
things along those lines that may cost
the state some toll Revenue
um and uh I'll let other I believe
there's other testimony coming so I
don't want to take their steal their
Thunder but
um things you know things like that I I
can't so much speak for other states I
know when we're looking for a mass
vehicle
um we always have to assume that it may
only have one plate on it and we're
looking for it in our town
it slows down our process an awfully lot
because if the car is parked say in a
bank parking lot or something like that
the officer
um and it's uh it's backed in with no
place showing we've got to get out of
our car and go around and and try and
look at it
um you know as long as it's it's as it's
parked in a place that we would consider
playing view so I apologize if I
digressed a little I hope I answered
your question
further questions from the committee
and then thank you thank you very much
it was a pleasure and an honor
good afternoon
uh that's all I have signed up to speak
is there anybody else from the public
that would wish to speak to this or has
anybody else added on
yeah I signed up Mr chair as a close
sponsor to speak on it okay uh
representative
um
questions
[Music]
thank you
oh
is it me I don't know what to say well
he just came in the the tech just came
in and worked on these bikes earlier
this is evolves this works can anybody
here to marry you
grab that microphone
right nuts all right
without reason without talking into it
okay
um well I was speak as loud as I can
anyway as I was saying and I apologize
if you can't hear me at home
um
I'm testifying today in superb of this
bill
19 States currently only require one
because when you when you attach it
front license plate of roughly all
vehicles not just collectible vehicles
you usually end up damaging the bumper
to do it most cars
somebody takes a lot to screwed it into
the front bumper and that does damage
and it doesn't devalue the car
now you could argument that URL if
you've put a seller card or something
New Hampshire maybe it doesn't make a
difference but the fact of the matter is
that sometimes you sell a vehicle out of
state and I know for a fact that any
vehicle that goes through one plate only
state
um the vehicles work less because you
have pairs now on the bumper
so that's one issue and the evidence
that the big of that designed to have a
front license plate now you didn't uh
testimony that
you know it's a small license plate on a
2 000 pound Vapor well the fact of the
it's all about aerodynamics these days
more and more apparently becoming more
slippery dynamically to increase fuel
efficiency it's not an all-around
proposition it's it's tuned with
everything you do with the vehicle so
having that problem which is a blunt uh
surface in the Airstream does make the
disrupted airflow around the plate that
also can
impact the radiator from getting clean
air through it as well so that that is
an issue in regard to
uh license plates scanners in the state
they're here they're being used their
their use is going to continue to be
used more and more you know as we go on
in time
[Music]
we put a testimonial past that
those plates can read the plate
on the back it doesn't need a front
plate to read it now we've heard that
well if the place obstructed well
this this pill doesn't prevent or
happiness but it doesn't prevent
somebody from from taking them off a
license plate front hold back or or you
know putting something
on the vehicle like to block the plate
so that that's kind of a side issue from
what this this plate uh addresses of
what this bill addresses
as far as leaving a plane
on the front of the vehicle try doing
that when you're on the road on a
two-lane road where you're traveling at
50 60 miles an hour with a progress or
120 miles an hour you heard the last
seven digits are most placed out it's
it's very difficult if not impossible to
you may get one or two digits but it's
not so easy to do also keep in mind that
at night these plates aren't lit so
there's a requirement to have the rear
plate lit the front plate is no
requirement and you cannot see them at
night at all so
it's my opinion that the the value of
having two plates is minimal
the state would save some money by only
manufacturing one plant it's not a lot
of money
um
and for these reasons uh I support and
hope you uh the committee finds it
through uh
OTP
for uh for passing this
this one plate pocket now keep in mind
that if I'm committed those drafted if
somebody decides they want to have a
second plate nothing in this bill
prevents them from having a second plate
so it gives people the option that want
to go that way if you do if you don't
want to do it you don't have to
um and you know there's always the
sky is falling kind of attitude I would
suggest that if this committee passed
this and this became law
um I don't think you'd hear anymore
nothing structured from going back in in
having legislation
so I hope we we decide to do this now
this has been before the committee
several times I've talked to several
people in the 19 states and
the wrong room it doesn't have a deal
with it and
keep in mind too we New Hampshire we
don't have a sign at the board that says
if you only have one license plate you
can't drive in New Hampshire you have
vehicles for many of these other states
that drive here
um there's never an issue collecting
um the Easy Pass toll in fact I have a
relative that lives in Florida which is
a one-plate state and I've driven that
vehicle here two of themselves it's
never been a problem so
um sometimes we're afraid but I hope you
you considered supporting the Bill thank
you
thank you representative I've got a
couple of hands up uh representative
Sykes
he's not gonna hear my answer probably
no I could actually finally thank you
representative thank you uh chairman
Walsh
um I have a question for you chairman
Walsh and then I have a question for
representative torosian do you have a
preference in the order that I asked
them
um I don't
okay I guess I'll ask representative
torosion my question of him first
because he's right there we've got a mic
that's working for him yay
um representative torosian you're one of
the co-sponsors of this bill
I am curious to know if you would be
opposed
to uh to considering a possibility that
the one license plate requirement would
only apply to antique vehicles and
perhaps some other types of vehicles
which by Design are not set up for it
um
he certainly will support that
um Amendment if it meant the difference
between
we certainly put up the barrel as it's
drafted but I would take that over
nothing and I would suggest if you want
to go down that road to consider
thank you for that Insight uh
representators and I appreciate it
I've added Collectibles to my uh very
short list here
um
Mr chairman
um in past years when we've heard this
bill there's been quite a lot of
discussion about toll collecting and and
the impacts for this uh one plate Bill
and yet today we didn't have any
testimony from the tall Pike toll uh
Turnpike Authority
where they typically are collecting
these tolls I wonder if there's some way
to get feedback from them to see if
anything has changed or do we go back to
the 2019 testimony to to learn how this
was
this bill will affect collection of
tolls
yeah representative I'll look into that
I was surprised not to see them there uh
Department of Safety either but maybe
they decided uh this isn't such a bad
Bill after all just perhaps uh maybe
they did maybe they didn't
help so I remember correctly we looked
with the brothers before us the main
thing in the audience was that the
Department of Transportation had was on
the cat Lanes that's they said that
their cameras on the cash Lanes
look at the front coat all the other
cameras that dealt with it looked at the
rear so the fact that they didn't have
it on the front did not apply to
anything other than the catch Lanes now
I know since then uh my husband passed
it they're going to start seeing them
disappear perhaps but I will look into
it and I'll see if I can get some
information
yeah I would Mr chairman respectfully I
would appreciate that that's not quite
how I remember their testimony so it'd
be really important for them to clarify
for us enough
representative
thank you I did have a question but um I
see on the participant side there's a
couple people with their hands raised
that um might be able to provide a
little more insight however
um
I did have one question I can't tell if
representative torosion is still there
or not
yes sir
okay
thank you representative torosian um you
you mentioned a cost saving since you're
only going to have to produce one plate
however the bill is exactly the same
version as HB 395 which we had in 2019
and it's simply written as an option to
only
display one plate and if I remember the
testimony from the DMV they said there
would be no savings because they would
still need to produce two plates for
every number because they wouldn't know
who would want to select only who only
one plate has something changed in that
um because I don't think this bill is
any different from the one we had two
years ago
thank you representative for the
question and no what's changed is it
would be
um you know if this will become more the
DNB would get a
they get a picture of well how many
vehicles
only would want either one or two
players in other words right now it's
someone of an unknown but the type of
matter is particularly on a new vehicle
you rather register you that you could
have a group of
okay development with two crates you
could have just the one plate in other
words
um when you when you register a vehicle
get a new credit
you're starting from scratch so I'm
getting really for registered
um there could be the option if you want
one place you can come out of this prior
place if you want to it's the the other
uh file so um
the reality is less racist place would
be printed and that should be a cost
savings again I said it would be a minor
save but nonetheless it should be a
savings
okay thank you I guess I would want to
hear testimony from the DMV on that if
if that's would be in the plans or not
thank you very much thank you
yeah we do have a few other times up I
recognize a couple of them any more
questions for representative throjan
soon
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
good afternoon Mr chairman can you hear
me
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm Captain
William Haynes I'm with the office of
Highway Safety but I'm here today also
representing Department of Safety and I
just want to indicate that the
department of safety is opposed to this
bill that we still feel very strongly
that for safety concerns and other
reasons that we should stay with the two
plate mandate and I just would like to
clarify one thing um there was a some
testimony that perhaps you can't see a
license plate in the front at night
however those plates are highly
reflective and with my 19 years of
Patrol in the roads I can read front
plates I I make it a practice to read
them as they go by me unless they're
obscured in some way so because they are
highly reflective and because of the
headlights that we have and especially
nowadays with some of the LED LED
headlights you can see them very clearly
and if you took on your way home this
evening hopefully you're not out that
late but if you were to be driving the
next evening and you you paid attention
you see that you couldn't Factory that
plate so again on both behalf office of
Highway Safety and Department of Safety
were opposed to uh only going to one
any questions for Captain Haynes from
the committee yes I have
representative
yes thank you
experience for your uh testimony and I'm
interested to know how do you feel about
uh if this bill were to be changed
to only uh allow vehicles that were
antiques or Collectibles to have just in
one plate
well that's an interesting question I I
know that's very um there's a very small
amount to those so I think the impact
would be minimal but I again I question
once we open that door whether we're
opening the door further I know I
personally own seven other modern hot
rods that it did hurt my feelings to
drill holes in the front bumper but I
realized that the uh the benefits from a
safety perspective clearly outweigh the
the two holes that I had to drill in my
bumper for what it's worth but
um I think from a department of safety
perspective we'd like to stay with the
two plates
yeah
thank you compare questions for Captain
Owens Haynes
representative
thank you again Mr chairman Captain
Haynes thank you um is what's the
purpose of a plate is there any reason
other than identification of the vehicle
and by that the owner also it does a
number of things actually I mean that's
its primary responsibilities is to
indicate that the vehicle is properly
registered
um and so one of the things we do and
and obviously you know that's tied to
revenues and everything else in our
state as significant revenues at the top
level but it what it does do is it
allows us to recognize immediately that
the person operating that vehicle that
vehicle is properly registered with that
plate and on that plate are stickers as
you know it's the year and then the
month of the year but it also identifies
that the vehicle is not only registered
in that year but helps us to Sister
ensure that that vehicle is is got the
right safety inspection for the right
period of time if I imagine the color of
the front plate verified it's within the
correct year and then look at
simultaneously at the windshield and
verifying that they're called a sticker
so it does a number of things outside of
crime but just for pure Traffic Safety
perspective uh in pure ensuring people
are complying with the laws and rules of
the state as it relates to safe
operation not safe operation but
operating vehicles that are safe to be
on our roadways
thank you very much for that
clarification
if there's a question from the committee
CNN thank you Captain Haynes thank you
very much
next
super seven
good afternoon can you hear me I know
good afternoon Mr chairman of members of
the committee for the record my name is
Jeff
oberdank and I am testifying on this
bill today on behalf of the Division of
Motor Vehicles and we are also in
opposition
to this bill for a number of reasons
which I will outline
the first is the language in the bill
wasn't clear if it included all plate
types
um as you know there are many different
plate types
um but but most importantly one of the
pieces of clarification that sought is
it says and further provided that a
passenger vehicle shall only be required
to display one number plate
or a passenger vehicle
um to us means school bus and motor
coach so if we're talking about the
passenger car
um that language change
would need to be done
um but specifically to talk a little bit
about what representative tolersky keyed
in on was our main talking point is the
distribution of place to 234 towns
at what percentage do we distribute
single plates versus two sets of plates
how do we begin to guess who's going to
take advantage of this program do we do
10 percent
get a single plate do we do 90 we think
are going to stay with the double plates
um there's a significant
significant amount of logistics behind
making sure 234 towns have the correct
plates are we to assume that everybody
gets two plates and that you simply
throw one plate out
uh do you no longer allow citizens to
walk into a DMV or a town and expect to
walk out with plates because now we
would order them and send them versus
having different plate types and stock
of Which percentage we're not sure
um so for all of those reasons and the
reasons described by by Captain Haynes
and State Police we are opposed
um to the bill as it's written and I'll
be happy to take any questions you may
have
thank you around any questions from the
committee
CNN thank you very much
thank you
I'll do my best with this Chris wanna
Christmas
well good afternoon
um
members of the committee Mr chair can
you can you hear me okay now good
afternoon congratulations to represent
please
I know the audio from the room is is a
little difficult to hear but um I just
want to make sure you can hear me so my
name is Chris waschock and I'm the
Deputy Commissioner of the Department of
Transportation
um I'd like to State the Departments
um concern with this bill this bill has
been
um before this Committee in the Years
passed
um the requirement that only the rear
plate of the passenger vehicle be
displayed is very problematic for the
Easy Pass system
um right now we have a system that can
capture both the front and the rear
plate and by eliminating one of those
options it certainly reduces our ability
to effectively be able to enforce any
violations or unpaid transactions I just
want to give some statistics on the Easy
Pass system for some of the members of
the committee in essence
um easy pass is used by 30 toll agencies
in 19 States the system provides a
seamless efficient effective way to
collect that toll from both in-state
residents and out-of-state users
particularly when we're talking about
Open Road tolling and all electronic
tolling which in essence will eliminate
the toll booth and cash option and go to
you know Seoul
um transponder base a license based
collection
um that is being implemented in the
Spalding Turnpike
in
um about 18 months to two years so the
department is moving towards that type
of approach
um the turnpike system also operates as
an Enterprise fund where all the revenue
collected on the system is used on the
system
you know certainly the system that
Revenue pays for the systems operation
and maintenance it pays for the
outstanding bonds that we use to build
the system it pays for RNR work or
renewal and reconstruction work to make
sure the system is in good work in order
and then the remaining revenues put to
the capital expansion program so all the
money is put right back into the system
in fiscal year 19 prior to the pandemic
131 million of total revenue was
collected in fiscal year 20 that Revenue
dropped to 118 million because of the
reduction in traffic
we collected 110 million transactions of
those 110 million transactions in fiscal
year 20 where no valid transponder was
read the license plate of the vehicle
was captured
roughly 6.4 million images were read
and according to our back office event a
roughly 60 percent of those images or
3.8 million of the front plate
so we're talking about a very very high
risk here
um when those images are read some of
those images uh basically categorized
and associated with the account in an
itol so for example is a pest account
holders that have transponders if for
some reason their transplant is not red
or they're sharing a transponder or they
have for whatever reason remove the
transponder from the windshield that
license plate is red and then that plate
is associated with the vehicle with with
the account and the toll was extracted
from the account with no issues
um
there's a seven day to pay provision so
if someone doesn't have an account goes
through they can go online and pay so
the license plate
um
that's captured is used by that um by
that aspect and then for those that um
do not pay we send them an invoice to
collect the tolls so it's very
concerning in a potential High Revenue
loss for the system if the front plate
is eliminated on vehicles
um the department provides
um I would say the department is highly
reliable on being able to capture both
plates many times and it's been noted
before in past testimony there may be a
bike rack on the rear there may be a
trailer being pulled there may be some
other a Prudence that's blocking the
rear plate and without the front plate
we would not be able to collect that
tool so having that redundancy and
ability to read either the front or the
rear plate is paranoid Paramount to
maximizing the collection of the toll
Revenue when there is no transponder
that's read in the lanes
Additionally the department does not
have rear cameras in all of its toe
Lanes the cash only Lanes at all the
toll plazas only have front cameras
installed to capture the violators so if
this bill is passed in addition to the
potential High Revenue loss and
electronic toll Lanes
the department would need to install
rear cameras in 26 lanes and an
estimated cost of nine thousand per Lane
with 234 thousand dollars so
um for the reasons above
the department cannot support this bill
um with the requirement that only one
license plate to rear plate the uh be
required and that concludes my testimony
I'll be happy to answer any questions
the committee may have and I believe my
testimony was also submitted
thank you Mr White Shark actually I have
a question
um yeah first of you did something
written testimony and if you did observe
it in the zoo the statistics that you
you told us about the uh how many
registered front plate recordings are
there
I'm sorry it's very difficult to discern
exactly what you you're asking
[Music]
other states
hi
I am sorry the way you're coming across
it's very mumbled and I cannot make out
any word that you're saying I apologize
I know if there's a better microphone
well I've been fighting with this thing
let me try somebody else see if you can
hear them our representative
I basically had the same question you
did Mr chairman well you can try it
maybe I can hear your representative
you can't hear me yes I can loud and
clear
okay maybe
I don't know
um so yeah well part of part of our
they each vehicles that only have one
license plate I mean are you losing
revenue from them
well
um so we do have the ability to capture
the rear plane
so in in those instances the rare play
is captured and certainly if they're
if that replay is blocked then yes that
is lost Revenue because
um you know we really don't have the
ability to have that added redundancy
now I will say that the majority of the
traffic on our system is from Maine New
Hampshire
in Massachusetts
uh Vermont is you know probably fourth
Vermont is the only state in New England
that has this one plate requirement I
will say and I downloaded and it was
actually last year so I don't know if
it's been updated you know which states
uh require only one plate and the
majority of the states
are southern states they don't have any
winter issues
and they likely other than Florida the
majority of those states don't have any
toll authorities
so
um I'm not saying that there aren't any
states without with the um without what
that have told authorities and only
require one plate but what I'm saying is
the vast majority of those 19 uh
southern states without toll authorities
so
um this is a serious serious concern for
for the Easy Pass system and the
potential of lost Revenue I cannot tell
you
how much lost Revenue that potentially
will be because you know right now
a vendor is the way that they're trained
they they automatically to fall to the
front plate and if that front plate is
legible they use that plate they don't
look at the rear plate and 60
I hope that answers your question
thank you so much
um
Mr Harris Jennifer yeah it's a quick
follow-up dinner question
um
um the 60 that were red of my plates was
that determined that the back plate was
unreadable was that just like a
different place first and that's where
it stopped no so what that meant so the
vendors process is that they typically
read the front plate first if that one
plate is legible they use that plate and
it's 60 of the time
you know that front plate is used the
other 40 the rear plate is used so
um in those cases where the rear plate
is used I can't say that the plate
was illegible and we haven't done that
level of analysis analysis
okay did you want to follow up
again
[Music]
I did not receive a copy of Mr
Washington's uh testimony so I'm
wondering
um I'm going to confirm we're going to
talk with uh and I don't even know if
anybody can hear him anymore at this
point I'll be talking with our
researcher and maybe staff to find out
figure out the best way to make sure
that committee members are getting all
this literature all this testimony I'm
not sure exactly what these are going to
do it right now that's why I'll get some
advice and reach out to everybody later
uh representative Walsh I do have
um his testimony it was emailed to the
full committee um however if some
committee members did not receive it
just let me know I can forward it over
thank you very much sir
thank you
Mr chairman I just wanted to point out
that his testimony was emailed to us but
it was sent from a Kathleen Hanson
and not directly from him so if you
search your email under Kathleen hampson
you will find it
okay
um we'll talk when we close this area on
the best way to make sure everybody's
getting their emails I know for a fact
some people are not uh I just want to
make sure that's resolved
um that is the last speaker that I have
seeing them seeing them okay uh in terms
of people who
've signed up
a little support of
uh we have representative Roy
representative Lucas representative oh
we
representative Craig representative
Smith Jonathan Smith
Representative Bob Greene
um
and
representative Alicia Lucas
we also have
my proposal from the New Hampshire
school of Transportation Association for
Dubose
and we have four members of the public
that are in support of uh Holly Bean
Alvin C
Alex weird widely I'm not sure and I
apologize one of them
um a friend is opposed so that's anybody
that has signed up for this bill
so with that being said I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
um before we go again like I said we'll
get this result with the emails
uh and I thank you for your patience
today with some of the downtime again I
had a change of plans whether it's
exciting
and uh
to be honest because you did not know
how it was going to go day one with this
this whole hybrid system I think it
might actually better better than I
thought it was so yes things should uh
get a little bit smoother next week the
girls I kept them mostly had a half an
hour piece again but yeah a little more
substantive so it's just like they're
not going to have as much downtime
I don't know the down times better than
being three hours behind because I've
been there and that is not a lot of fun
uh next week we will certainly be doing
executive session if you notice the
calendar is the last thing I think I
scheduled for 215 don't quickly on that
but uh that's not due end of our day we
will go into exact session uh after uh
next week the most part it'll be the
bills we've dealt with today
so unless there's any questions
we're good
so
thanks everybody and have a good
hmm